GOOD AFTERNOON I WILL GO AHEAD
AND.
GET STARTED ON OUR FIRST.
MEETING FOR THE ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
AS CHAIR WHEN THE FIRST.
WANT TO WELCOME MY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND PANELISTS ARE FOR
SELECT COMMITTEE MEETING.
COMMITTEE HEARING ON DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE I'D LIKE TO ALSO THINK
BLUESHIELD FIRST THING MY STAFF
AND HELPING TO PUT THE HEARING
TOGETHER I AM A HUGE CHAMPION I
HOPE TO BE ACTUALLY A HUGE
CHAMPION WHEN IT COMES TO
ADDRESSING AND PREVENTING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. PA ABUSE
THIS ISSUE AS YOU ALL KNOW IS
VERY NEAR AND DEAR TO MY HEART.
MY SISTER.
IS A SURVIVOR OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND I WANT TO DO
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE THAT I CAN.
OBVIOUSLY TO HELP HER CONTINUE
ON THIS AYE JOURNEY BITE TO
ASSIST A WOMEN AND MEN BECAUSE
IT'S NOT JUST THE.
WOMEN THAT ARE.
ABUSE DOMESTICALLY.
BUT HELP THEM GET THE RESOURCES
THAT THEY NEED AND THE SUPPORT
THAT THEY NEED TO GET THROUGH A
VERY VERY DIFFICULT ISSUE AND
NOT JUST THEIR LIVES BUT IN
THEIR FAMILY'S LIVES. I LEARNED
THAT IT'S NOT JUST AN ISSUE
BETWEEN THE ABUSER AND THE.
THE ABUSED BUT IT'S ALSO A
FAMILY ISSUE THAT WE TEND TO
LOOK AWAY FROM BECAUSE IT'S A
DIFFICULT ISSUE. I ALSO HAVE TO
SHARE WITH YOU THAT.
WHEN I GO ON SPEAKING.
.
ISSUES ARE ON SPEAKING TOWARDS
IF YOU WANT TO CALL THEM BUT I
AM WHEN I'M ASKED TO SPEAK I
ALWAYS.
TALK ABOUT THE ISSUE OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND IT'S VERY
INTERESTING TO ME.
TO SEE HOW MANY PEOPLE SHRINK.
IN THEIR SEATS WHILE I'M LOOKING
AT THEM IN THE AUDIENCE BECAUSE
IT'S NOT JUST A A TOUGH ISSUE TO
DEAL WITH AS A FAMILY MEMBER BUT
IT'S ALSO A VERY TOUGH ISSUE TO
DEAL WITH AS A SOCIETY AS A
COMMUNITY. AND SO MY HOPE I IS
THAT I'D BY BRINGING THESE
CONVERSATIONS TO LIFE WITH THE
SUPPORT OF US ARE OUR OTHER
FELLOW MEMBERS.
I AM VERY GRATEFUL TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON FOR BEING A
PARTNER WITH ME IN THIS.
TO BRING LIGHT TO NOT JUST MY
COMMUNITY BUT COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE SO I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THAT.
.
LAST YEAR THE GOVERNOR SIGNED IT
MY.
AB FIFTY FIVE FIFTY SEVEN WHICH
PROVIDES TEMPORARY HOUSING FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS FOR
APPLICANTS OF COW WORKS.
THIS YEAR ALL AYE ALONG WITH
SENATOR BAIL AND MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES ARE ADVOCATING FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO SUPPORT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS. AS
WELL AS SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
THERE'S TWO THINGS HAPPENING
FIRST IT'S A AN ACTUAL BILL
GOING THROUGH BUT IT'S A BIG
BUDGET ASK
AND SO I NEED YOUR HELP WE NEED
YOUR HELP.
AND ADVOCATING FOR THIS A
BUDGET.
ASK AT EVERYTHING'S GONNA BE
HAPPENING NEXT WEEK IN
CONFERENCE AND SO WERE WERE
KEEPING OUR CHRIS THE OUR
FINGERS CROSSED BUT MORE THAN
THAT WERE TALKING TO THE.
INTERESTED.
PARTIES THE ADVOCATES AND TO
THE POWERS THAT BE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY LOOK AT OUR BUDGET ASK
AS A REAL ISSUE THAT CAN. NOT
ONLY HELP US SURVIVORS BUT ALSO
HELP US SAVE MONEY BY THAT.
HELPING.
SOME OF THESE.
POTENTIAL DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
VICTIMS PREVENT THEIR DOMESTIC
ABUSE BY BEING MORE EDUCATED AND
HOPEFULLY THE MONEY WILL TAKE US
THERE SO AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY.
AND I WANT TO.
HANDED OVER TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SEE
SOME WORDS.
SURE PERSONAS IT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO.
Y. CHAIRWOMAN THE MISS RUBIO
FOUR ONE HAVING TO SELECT
COMMITTEE NOW ALSO CONVENING ON
TODAY'S HEARING I THINK IS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT SPECIAL YOU LOOK
AT THAT THIS THAT THE
STATISTICS.
ARE AMONG JUST PUTTING UP SO A
FEW NOTES THE NUMBER OF A OF
AMERICAN TROOPS KILLED IN
AFGHANISTAN AND IRAQ BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND ONE AND TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE A SIX THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT. THE NUMBER
OF AMERICAN WOMEN WHO WERE
MURDERED BY CURRENT OR X. MALE
PARTNERS DURING THE SAME TIME
WAS ELEVEN THOUSAND AND SEVEN
HUNDRED SIXTY SIX.
THAT'S ALARMING.
THAT'S ALARMING WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
VICTIMIZED.
BY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
CERTAINLY I AM LOOKING FORWARD
TO THE DISCUSSION TO THE ROBUX.
CONVERSATION EXCHANGE ALSO THE
TESTIMONIES OF THOSE WHO ARE
SURVIVORS AND ALSO THOSE WHO I'M
DIDN'T SURVIVE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
WE SHOULD NEVER FORGET ABOUT
THOSE INDIVIDUALS ABOUT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN. ON TO PROTECT THIS
GENERATION.
ARE UP AGAINST DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SO I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE
ANSWER TO LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATION TODAY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON.
AND IF I. WOULD LIKE TO CALL
OUR FIRST PANEL UP OF A IN THE
TITLE IS FINDING INNOVATIVE
APPROACHES AND FOCUSING ON
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PREVENTION. IF
I LOSE YOU CRAWL PENA SENIOR
PRODUCT PROGRAM OFFICER FOR BLUE
SHIELD OF CALIFORNIA CAN COME UP
I'D REALLY.
WOULD BE GREAT TO.
.
HAVE YOU UP HERE AND WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO.
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION AND
LIKE ASSEMBLY MEMBER A GIPSON
STATE AS STATED.
THE NUMB NUMBERS ARE ALARMING
AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN.
AFTER THAT'S DISCUSSION WE CAN
ALL TALK ABOUT.
POTENTIAL OUTCOMES FROM THIS SO
THANK YOU AND A. WHO I WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE YOU TO LET
DIONYSIAC CROPPING OF THE SENIOR
PROGRAM OFFICER CRUCIAL? THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN HELLO
EVERYONE UP MY NAME IS YOU SEE
UNCLE RAT BANG AND I'M THE
SENIOR PROGRAM OFFICER FOR BLUE
SHIELD OF CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION.
I LEAD OUR BREAK THE CYCLE
INITIATIVE AND GO AND VERY HAPPY
TO BE HERE FIRST I I WANT TO
THANK THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. OF FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY I WANT TO
THANK THE MEMBERS AND ESPECIALLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUDY REVEAL FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND REVIVING
THIS SELECT COMMITTEE ON
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
IT IS A CRITICAL TIME TO START
LOOKING AT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AT
THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SYSTEM OF
CARE. AND EQUALLY IMPORTANT AT
THE NEED FOR PREVENTION AND YOU
REALLY WE REALLY.
FRAMED THE ISSUE AND VERY
SIMILAR TO THE WAY WE'RE LOOKING
AT IT AS WELL.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN.
OF THE CURRENT ENVIRONMENT
FUELED BY THE WOMEN'S MARCHES ME
TOO TIMES UP STAND UP AND THE
INCREASING CONNECTION BETWEEN
GUN VIOLENCE AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SHINES A LIGHT.
ON THE ISSUE AND THE NEED FOR
ITS PREVENTION.
A AT A TIME WHEN SO MANY
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA ARE
UNDER ATTACK.
WE NEED TO CREATE NEW SOLUTIONS
THAT PROMOTE SAFETY AND WELL
BEING.
THIS MOMENT IN HISTORY IS
GARNERING YOU KNOW MULTI
GENERATIONAL VOICES AND
ADVOCATES.
ACROSS THE NATION DOES THE
ACROSS THE STATE THE NATION AND
THE WORLD AND WE APPLAUD THIS
COMMITTEE FOR HOLDING TODAY'S
HEARING.
AS THE LARGEST PRIVATE FUNDER OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN CALIFORNIA
BLUE SHIELD OF CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION IS THRILLED ABOUT THE
WORK THAT YOU WILL BE DOING IN
THE COMING MONTHS AND YEARS.
THE MISSION OF THE OF THE BLUE
SHIELD OF CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION
IS TO BUILD LASTING AN EQUITABLE
SOLUTIONS TO MAKE CALIFORNIA THE
HEALTHIEST STATE AND.
TO END DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
UP OVER THE PAST SIXTEEN YEARS
THE FOUNDATION HAS MADE OVER A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
GRANTS TO COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE TO STRENGTHENING
CALIFORNIA SAFETY NET. FOR
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
WE HAVE INVESTED IN THE CRISIS
RESPONSE SAFETY NET THROUGH CORE
OPERATING SUPPORT SERVICE
INNOVATIONS TO DEEPEN THE REACH
IN THE QUALITY OF SERVICES. AND
HAVE FUNDED FIELD CAPACITY
DEVELOPMENT INCLUDING LEADERSHIP
ORGANIZATIONAL STRENGTHENING AND
NETWORK BUILDING.
IN CARRYING OUT THE STRATEGY WE
HAVE LEARNED A GREAT DEAL FROM
OUR WORK AND FROM OUR PARTNERS
AND HAVE MANY SUCCESS STORIES TO
SHARE AS WELL AS A FEW FAILURES.
TODAY YOU WILL HEAR FROM THREE
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE ADVANCING
INNOVATIONS FROM TO FOUNDATION
INITIATIVES THAT WERE DESIGNED
TO IMPROVE THE CULTURAL
RESPONSIVENESS OF THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE FIELD AND TO INTEGRATE
CARE ACROSS THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND PRIMARY HEALTH CARE
SETTINGS.
THE FOCUS AND LEADERSHIP OF
THESE THREE ORGANIZATIONS
REPRESENT SEGMENTS.
OF THE CURRENT AND FUTURE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF OUR STATE.
THEY FILL IMPORTANT GAPS IN THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SYSTEM OF CARE
FOR VULNERABLE SURVIVORS AND
ADDRESS GAPS ROOTED IN RESEARCH
REGARDING NEEDS OF UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES.
THEY AND OTHERS ARE SHARING
THEIR PRACTICES AND PARTNERING
ACROSS THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
FIELD. YOU WILL LEARN ABOUT HOW
THEY ARE PARTNERING WITH
COMMUNITIES.
HOW THEY ARE PROMOTING SURVIVOR
AND COMMUNITY LEADERSHIP THEY'RE
COORDINATING CARE ACROSS THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS? AND ENGAGING
FAITH BASED ON AND WHO WANT
INFLUENTIAL COMMUNITY LEADERS
AND ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS CLERGY
AND CHURCHES.
WHICH IS  POWERFUL STEP TOWARD
SHIFTING COMMUNITY NORMS AROUND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
AS YOU KNOW THE IMPACT OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ON OUR NATION
AND STATE RUNS DEEP ONE IN THREE
WOMEN WILL EXPERIENCE INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE IN THEIR
LIFETIME. AND A SURVEY WE
COMMISSIONED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
SHOWED THAT FIFTY EIGHT PERCENT
OF CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN EITHER
TOUCH TO BUY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
EITHER AS A VICTIM. AS AN ABUSER
THEMSELVES OR THROUGH A CLOSE
FRIEND OR FAMILY MEMBER.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS A COMPLEX
PROBLEM AS YOU FRAMED EARLIER IT
CAUGHT ITS ITS CAUSES OCCUR OVER
THE SPAN OF YEARS OR DECADES.
AND IT'S IT AND IT'S IMPACTS
AFFECT MORE THAN TWO INDIVIDUALS
IT EVERBERATES THROUGHOUT THE
LIVES IN NOT JUST OF THE
INDIVIDUAL SURVIVOR OR THE
ABUSER BUT ALSO THEIR CHILDREN
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES.
CHRONIC HEALTH CONDITIONS FOR
SURVIVORS ARE WELL DOCUMENTED
AND THE ADVERSE CONSEQUENCES TO
CHILDREN WHO WITNESS PARENTAL
VIOLENCE ARE AMONG THE RISK
FACTORS THAT ARE FOUNDATION IS
CONCERNED ABOUT.
AS YOU WILL SEE AND ONE OF THE
HANDOUTS THAT YOU HAVE THE COST
TO THE HEALTH SYSTEM ESTIMATE IS
ESTIMATED TO HE IN THE BILLIONS.
AND WE KNOW THAT THIS DATA IS
INCOMPLETE
WE KNOW BECAUSE MANY VICTIMS DO
NOT REPORT THEIR ABUSE.
IT IS CLEAR THAT IN ADDITION TO
MEETING THE MOST IMMEDIATE AND
PRESSING NEEDS OF VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS WE ALSO NEED TO CREATE
NEW KINDS OF SOLUTIONS AND
PREVENTION APPROACHES.
OVER THE PAST YEAR THE
FOUNDATION HAS BEEN EXPLORING
HOW WE CANINVEST MORE
STRATEGICALLY IN PREVENTING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
WE HAVE LEARNED THAT A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HAS ITS OWN ROOT CAUSES
AND COMMUNITY DETERMINANTS
THE PIPELINE FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE PERPETRATION AND
VICTIMIZATION OFTEN STARTS WITH
CHILDHOOD EXPOSURE TO ABUSE AND
CONTINUES TO EARLY ADULTHOOD.
WHILE THERE IS LESS ROBUST DATA
ON HIGHLY EFFECTIVE PREVENTION
PRACTICES AND PROGRAMS THERE'S
ALSO A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO
INVEST IN EXPERIMENTATION
LEARNING AND SCALING PROMISING
PREVENTION APPROACHES.
WE HAVE ALSO LEARNED THAT WHEN
IT COMES TO IMPROVING THE LIVES
OF CALIFORNIANS THERE IS NO SUCH
THING AS A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH.
OUR STATE IS MADE UP OF MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE AND THOUSANDS OF
COMMUNITIES.
EACH WITH ITS UNIQUE SET OF
ASSETS AND STRUGGLING WITH A
UNIQUE SET OF CHALLENGES.
AS THE FOUNDATION LOOKS FORWARD.
WE LOOK TO PROMOTE UP BOTH
HEALING AND PREVENTION OF
VIOLENCE AT MULTIPLE POINTS
ALONG THE INDIVIDUAL'S LIFESPAN.
WE WILL DO THIS BY REDUCING
EXPOSURE AND SUPPORTING YOU PREP
PREVENTION PRACTICES FOR HELP UP
FOR CHILDREN MOST AT RISK.
UP PREVENTING RELATIONSHIP
VIOLENCE TO USE ENGAGEMENT
MODELS ADOLESCENT RESILIENCY AND
PEER TO PEER PROGRAMS.
WE'RE GOING TO FOCUS ON
COMMUNITY AND FAMILY BASED
APPROACHES TO ADDRESS BOTH OF
THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THE
PREVENTION OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
BUT ALSO LEVERAGING GENDER
SPECIFIC STRATEGIES. CROSS
SECTOR COLLABORATIONS AND
COALITIONS.
WE ALSO WANT IDENTIFY
OPPORTUNITIES TO GENERATE PUBLIC
AWARENESS BOTH AT THE STATE AND
COMMUNITY LEVEL AND YOU POLICIES
THAT CAN HELP TRANSFORM GENDER
VIOLENCE NORMS AND REDUCE
PREVAILING STATEMENTS.
AS YOU MENTIONED DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IS SO OFTEN INVISIBLE
AND CONVERSATIONS.
IN ITS ITS REALLY SHOCKING TO
US TO SEE THAT YOU KNOW FEELS
LIKE HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS.
IF YOU WANT TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS YOU HAVE TO BE
THINKING ABOUT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AS A DRIVER A LOT OF A LOT OF
THE HOMELESSNESS AS AN EXAMPLE.
THE FOUNDATION BELIEVES STRONGLY
IN WORKING WITH SURVIVORS TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THEY DEFINE
SUCCESS.
AND WE ARE SEEING THE POWER OF
SURVIVOR SENATE INQUIRY AS
DRIVING MUCH OF THE CHANGE THAT
IS INFORMING OUR NEW DIRECTION
TOWARD PREVENTION.
WE ARE AT A TIME WHERE WERE
WITNESSING THE POWER OF LIVED
EXPERIENCE TO DRIVE CHANGE.
INDIVIDUAL STORIES ARE DERIVING
UNDERSTANDING CONNECTION AND
AWARENESS AND YOU WILL HEAR
COMPELLING STORIES TODAY FROM
OUR OTHER SPEAKERS.
THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT A
WINDOW HAS OPENED UP TO MAKE
INROADS TO ADDRESS HARMFUL
GENDER BASED NORMS THAT
INFLUENCE THE EXTENT TO WHICH WE
CAN TRULY AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
THE OPPORTUNITY IS ESPECIALLY
STRONG HEARING CALIFORNIA WHERE
WE HAVE VISIBLE STATE INDUSTRY
AND MOVEMENT LEADERSHIP. THIS
HEARING IS A GREAT EXAMPLE OF
THE QUALITY OF THE LEADERSHIP
THAT WE HAVE.
WE ARE IN A RENEWED MOMENT THAT
DEMANDS INCLUSION AND EQUITY TO
PREVENT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
PROMOTE EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK LIVE AND PLAY. IN SAFETY
AND. HEALTHY CONDITIONS MORE
THAN THAT WE ALL DESERVE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR FULL AND
PRODUCTIVE ENGAGEMENT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
AT THE FOUNDATION WE BELIEVE ITS
POSSIBLE TO IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS AND EVERY DAY
WE COLLABORATE WITH FORWARD
THINKING PARTNERS LIKE TODAY'S
PRESENTERS AND OTHERS WHO ARE
COMMITTED TO SEEKING OUT THE
BEST AND MOST INNOVATIVE.
SOLUTIONS THAT ADVANCE
EVERYONE'S WELL BEING.
WE HOPE TO BE A RESOURCE TO THIS
COMMITTEE AS YOU EMBARK ON THE
IMPORTANT WORK.
THAT YOU ARE EMBRACING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I I WANT TO OPEN IT UP TO THE
COMMITTEE IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ARM.
REGARDING.
THIS OR ANYTHING THAT YOU MAY
WANT TO.
DISCUSS.
OKAY WHAT THINK YOU ARM AND.
I HAVE TO I THINK PART OF THAT
THIS COULD BE MY OPENING
COMMENTS WERE ABOUT HOW WE HAVE
TO LOOK AT. ARE EVERYTHING
THAT'S GOING ON.
AND TRY TO ADDRESS THAT AND I
PRIOR TO THE THE BEGINNING OF
THE MEETING I WAS HAVING A
CONVERSATION WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. GIPSON IN THEM BRITAIN
REFLECTING ON WHAT I'M LISTENING
TO WHAT YOU'RE SAYING I AM.
.
THE REFLECTION IS IN THE COMMENT
THAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON WERE OUT
WERE MAKING AS I SAID.
YOU KNOW WE TO HELP EVERYBODY
BOB LINE AS. WE ALSO NEED TO
HELP THE ABUSER.
AND IMMEDIATELY I TENSED UP.
I TENSED UP BECAUSE I SAID AND
I'M YOU KNOW I'M AYE IF I'M
GOING TO BE OPEN AND TRANSPARENT
I HAVE TO SAY I SAID I DON'T
CARE ABOUT THE ABUSER.
I SAID THAT BACKING OUT OF MY
MOUTH.
AND BECAUSE I HAVE SUCH.
UP FEELINGS
OF OF.
I HATE
IF YOU WELL I'D TOWARDS
WHAT MY SISTER WENT THROUGH SO
RIGHT AWAY I SAID I DON'T CARE
ABOUT THE ABUSER.
AND I ASSEMBLY MEMBER GETS THEN
HAD A FABULOUS RESPONSE IF YOU
CAN BE SURE AND I AND I THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY SAID THAT WE ALSO
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE. A
PERPETRATOR.
ALSO GET THE HELP THAT THEY
NEED SO THEY CAN STOP WE HAVE TO
BREAK WE HAVE TO BREAK THE
CYCLE.
BECAUSE I BELIEVE HURT PEOPLE
HURT PEOPLE OTHER PEOPLE AND
IT'S LIKE BULLIES SMALL BULLIES
GROW UP TO BE BIG BULLIES AND
THEY TAKE THAT BULLY MENTALITY
INTO RELATIONSHIPS. AND IT
BECOMES ABUSIVE AND SO I THINK
IT'S SYSTEMIC I THINK WE NEED TO
HELP THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
AS WELL.
HOPEFULLY THEY CAN YOU KNOW GET
THE KIND OF HELP THAT THEY NEED
SO THEY CAN BREAK THE CYCLE OF
ABUSE.
BUT WE KNOW WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT BECAUSE THE U. LOOKING
THERE'LL NEVER NAY LIFESTYLE
THEY MAY HAVE ALSO BEEN ABUSE.
AND SOME KIND OF WAY TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OR SOMETHING
ELSE.
THANK YOU AND AND THAT'S.
WHAT'S MY OWN REFLECTION IN THE
LAST YOU KNOW FIFTEEN MINUTES
BECAUSE I'M THE FIRST ONE LIKE I
SAID I WAS LIKE I DON'T CARE.
AND AND.
I MEAN I ARE ALREADY IN FIFTEEN
MINUTES I HAD AN AHA MOMENT AYE
AS TO HOW I HAVE TO ALSO CHANGE
MY MENTALITY IN MY APPROACH TO.
THIS WHOLE.
THE ISSUE OF DOMESTIC ABUSE
BECAUSE AGAIN FOR ME OF THE
PAPERS REACTION IS LIKE I DON'T
CARE. YOU KNOW AND AND I CAN'T
HAVE THAT.
WAY WE LOOK AT WHAT'S HAPPENING
I ALSO HAVE TO CHANGE MY
MENTALITY AND THE DEPTH ADDRESS
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THAT
REFLECTION BECAUSE I AM
STRUGGLING WITH WHAT I JUST
SAID.
I AM REALLY STRUGGLING BUT IT'S
ALSO AN EXAMPLE AS TO HOW
SOCIETY AND AND OUR NEIGHBORS
OR.
ARE ARE STRUGGLING WITH WHAT'S
HAPPENING SO THANK YOU AYE YES
ABSOLUTELY.
I HAVE ONE QUESTION FOR YOU.
WE KNOW THAT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
HURT EVERYONE NOT ONLY.
THE INDIVIDUALS AND INVOLVED
BUT ALSO IF THERE'S A HUSBAND.
BUSE OF OF A WIFE
WHO HAVE CHILDREN NORMAL.
AND SO THEY ARE ALSO VICTIMS AS
WELL SOAKING TALK ABOUT SERVICES
THAT YOUR THE YOU KNOW THAT.
YOUR ORGANIZATION PROVIDES TO
THE ENTIRE FAMILY BECAUSE IT
TIRE FAMILY HAS TO ALSO HEAL AS
WELL.
ME AS A FORMER POLICE OFFICER I
CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY TIMES I
HAD TO GO IN A SITUATION. WHERE
I HAD TO ARREST?
THE HUSBAND IN THIS CASE.
FOR PUTTING HIS HANDS ON HIS
WIFE.
AND YOU HAVE KIDS CRYING.
KIDS HOLLERING AND YOU KNOW I'M
THE BAD GUY BECAUSE I'VE TAKE
YOUR DAD TO JAIL. RIGHT AND THEN
YOU HAVE A SITUATION WHERE THE
OUGHT MOTHER THE SPOUSE OR THE
PARTNER DON'T WANT TO PRESS
CHARGES
BECAUSE LOVE IS INVOLVED.
RIGHT AND YOU KNOW.
AND I KNOW WE HAVE LAWS ON THE
BOOKS WERE EVEN.
EVEN THOUGH THE VICTIM DON'T
WANT TO PRESS CHARGES THE STATE
CAN STILL PRESS CHARGES ON
BEHALF OF SPECIAL WHEN THERE'S
VISIBLE SIZE BUT CAN YOU TALK
ABOUT.
SERVICES IN WHICH YOU PROVIDE
FOR THE ENTIRE FAMILY WHO NEEDS
TO HEAL WHO'S BEEN HURT BY THIS
YEAH SITE I DO WANT TO SAY WE'RE
NOT A PROVIDER WHERE A FUNDER.
SO.
THAT I I THINK WHAT YOU HAVE
THAT THE TWO OF YOU ARE SPEAKING
TO IS. THIS THIS. UP A VERY KIND
OF THERE'S A VISION OF WHAT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS AND WERE
ALL LOCKED INTO IT YOU KNOW
IT'S.
A MAN HE NO WOMAN AND YEAH
THEY'RE THE ONLY TWO PEOPLE IN A
RELATIONSHIP THAT ARE AFFECTED
AND WHAT YOU'RE SPEAKING TO IS
THE BROADER WORLD. AND.
AND THERE AND AT THE REAL WORLD
EXCUSE ME AND THE FACT THAT YOU
DO HAVE.
CHILDREN OF WHO ARE WITNESSING
THIS VIOLENCE AND.
WE ACTUALLY I WILL SAY THAT WE
HAVE BEEN IN LOCKSTEP WITH THE
DOMESTIC.
WE HAVE NOT CHALLENGE SOME OF
THOSE UNDERLYING ASSUMPTIONS
ABOUT.
ABOUT THE NEED FOR CRISIS
RESPONSE WE HAVE FUNDED IT FULLY
WITH THE WITH THE INTENTION OF
STRENGTHENING THE SAFETY NET
AND.
FUNDING INNOVATIONS BUT ONE OF
THE EXCITING THINGS ABOUT THE
FOLKS IN THIS ROOM IS THAT THEY
CAN SPEAK MORE TO THE KINDS OF
FAMILY BASED APPROACHES THAT ARE
CULTURALLY SPECIFIC. ON THAT
THEY ARE INNOVATING AND
EXPERIMENTING AROUND TO DO MORE
THAN JUST WORKED WITH THE
SURVIVOR.
I WILL SAY THAT YOU ARE RIGHT
ON ASSEMBLY MEN GIPSON THAT.
.
WE ARE LOOKING AT THE EXPOSURE
TO VIOLENCE AS A RISK FACTOR FOR
NACHOS VICTIMIZATION BUT
PERPETRATION.
I'M AND TO THE POINT OF THAT YOU
WERE SAYING EARLIER ABOUT THE
USER ABUSE THAT WE KNOW THAT.
YOU KNOW ABUSERS ARE MEN AND
WOMEN AND WE ARE REALLY TRYING
TO THINK ABOUT THE TRAUMA
INFORMED APPROACHES TO BOTH
PARTIES AND THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
HOPING TO DO A LOT OF A TESTING
AROUND WHAT PREVENTION
APPROACHES COULD WORK.
THANK YOU I'M DO YOU HAVE ANY
SUGGESTIONS ARE IF YOU DON'T
HAVE THEM NOW PERHAPS SEND THEM
TO US ON HOW OF. WAYS THAT THE
SELECT COMMITTEE CAN.
SUPPORT THE WORK OF THE
FOUNDATION.
YET THANK YOU FOR THANK YOU FOR
ASKING THAT I'M HOPING THAT WE
CAN BE A RESOURCE AS WE MAKE
THIS PIVOT TOWARD DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE PREVENTION AND AT THE
SAME TIME REALLY TRYING TO.
CONTINUE OUR EXISTING
PARTNERSHIPS AND REALLY THINK
DIFFERENTLY I THINK WERE IN A
MOMENT.
MANY MOMENTS OF.
CHANGING MINDSETS AYE AND.
LIKE IT LIKE YOU MENTIONED
EARLIER LIKE I I WILL SAY THAT
FOR MYSELF I WILL OUR FOUNDATION
IT DIDN'T EVEN DIDN'T FIND ANY
PROGRAMS FOR ABUSERS WE ACTUALLY
STILL DON'T.
BUT WE ARE TRYING TO THINK
ABOUT.
THE ROLE OF MEN AS ALLIES AND
WE ARE FUNDING SOME EXPERIMENT
SOME OF SOME REALLY GREAT WORK
AROUND BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR.
AND IT'S SO WEIRD TO WE ARE ALSO
EXPANDING OUR MINDSET AND WE ARE
YOU WOULD LOVE TO BE A RESOURCE
TO YOU AND SHARE WITH ALL OF YOU
WHAT WE'RE LEARNING. AND TO THAT
WOULD BE MY ASK OF YOU IS TO.
IT'S TO BE.
IT FOR US TO SHARE RESOURCES
THAT WE ARE INVESTING IN AND
THAT HOPEFULLY WOULD BE OF OF
ASSISTANCE TO YOUR WORK.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE COMMENTS.
OKAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR FOR THE INFORMATION AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO.
HAVING MANY MORE CONVERSATIONS
WITH YOU AS TO WHAT WHAT WE CAN
DO AND.
HOW WE CAN PARTNER WITH YOU
THANK YOU?
KATE NEXT.
I WOULD LIKE TO CALL UP CONNIE
CHUNG JOB.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF KOREAN
AMERICAN FAMILY SERVICES THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY.
I COME FROM A FAMILY WITH THREE
GENERATIONS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
MY MOM SHARES THE STORY OF BEING
A TEENAGER AND COMING HOME FROM
SCHOOL ONE DAY.
AND SEEING HER MY GRANDFATHER
YET AGAIN HITTING MY
GRANDMOTHER.
SO MY MOM WENT UP TO HER ROOM.
AND SHE SLIT HER WRISTS.
AND SHE WROTE A MESSAGE TO HER
FATHER IN HER OWN BLOOD.
AND IT SAID IF I EVER HAVE TO
SEE YOU HIT MY MOM AGAIN. I WILL
KILL MYSELF.
I THINK HOW DESPERATE.
MY MOTHER MUST HAVE FELT.
THAT THE ONLY WAY SHE COULD
PROTECT.
MY GRANDMOTHER FROM ABUSE.
AND PROTECT HERSELF FROM HAVING
TO WITNESS IT.
WAS OFFER HOME LIFE.
SHE WAS A NORTH KOREAN REFUGEE.
GROWING UP IN SOUTH KOREA.
THAT HAD JUST BEEN UP RAVAGED BY
CIVIL WAR.
THERE WERE NO RESOURCES FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AT THAT TIME.
AND I THINK ABOUT HOW HOPELESS
MY GRANDMOTHER MUST'VE FELT IN
HER SITUATION.
AS A REFUGEE HER ENTIRE FAMILY
WAS UP NORTH NEVER TO BE HEARD
OF FROM AGAIN.
EVEN IF THEY HAD BEEN NEARBY.
THEY WOULD NOT HAVE SUPPORTED
HER LEAVING HER HUSBAND
ABANDONING HER WIFELY DUTIES AND
BRINGING SHAME TO THE FAMILY.
SHE WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
SURVIVE ON HER OWN
INDEPENDENTLY.
AS A WOMAN WITH ONLY SIX GRADE
EDUCATION AND FIVE CHILDREN BY
THE TIME SHE WAS THIRTY ONE.
NOW FAST FORWARD OVER HALF A
CENTURY LATER HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES.
WELL I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF CREATE AMERICAN FAMILY
SERVICES OR KAYFABE.
WE ARE RESOURCE CENTER FOR CREAN
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY THREE.
WE SERVE SEVEN THOUSAND CLIENTS
A YEAR. INCLUDING SOME TWO
HUNDRED VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
RTV CLIENTS.
ALMOST ALL WHO ARE MONOLINGUAL
KOREAN IMMIGRANT WOMEN.
FALL INTO THREE GROUPS.
ABOUT A THIRD OF OUR CLIENTS ARE
RECEIVING SERVICES FROM US.
WHILE LIVING IN OTHER SHELTERS
NEARBY WHERE THEY'RE RECEIVING
LIFESAVING SUPPORT AS THEY
REBUILT THEIR LIVES AND LIVE
INDEPENDENTLY.
ABOUT A THIRD OF OUR CLIENTS ARE
LIVING INDEPENDENTLY EITHER
HAVING BYPASS THE SHELTERS OR
HAVING GRADUATED.
BUT THE LAST ONE THIRD ARE
RECEIVING SERVICES FROM US.
WHILE THEY CONTINUE TO LIVE WITH
THEIR ABUSERS.
FOR THESE QUICK CLIENTS.
WHEN WE EDUCATE THEM ON THEIR
OPTIONS FOR SHELTERS.
THEY WEIGH THEIR OPTIONS AND
THEY SAY.
I COULD LEAVE MY HUSBAND.
MY IN LAWS MY CHURCH BASICALLY
EVERYONE I KNOW IN THIS COUNTRY.
IN ORDER TO MOVE INTO A HOUSE.
WHERE WILL BE COMPLETELY
ISOLATED?
BECAUSE THE OTHER RESIDENTS
DON'T SPEAK MY LANGUAGE.
THEY DON'T EAT MY FOOD.
THEY DON'T KNOW MY CULTURE.
EVEN IF I WERE TO ENTER SHELTER
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN I EVENTUALLY
HAVE TO LEAVE.
I DON'T SPEAK ENGLISH.
I'VE NEVER WORKED IN THE US I
DON'T HAVE JOB SKILLS HERE.
IN MANY CASES THERE
UNDOCUMENTED.
HOW WOULD I SURVIVE HOW WOULD I
SUPPORT MY CHILDREN?
FOR THIS SUBSET.
OF ARE MOST VULNERABLE CLIENTS
WHO CANNOT LEAVE.
THEIR SITUATION FEELS TO ME.
AS DESPERATE AS IT WAS.
FOR MY NORTH KOREAN REFUGEE
GRANDMOTHER.
GROWING UP IN A WAR TORN COUNTRY
IN SOUTH KOREA.
DESPITE ALL THE RESOURCES WE
HAVE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THE STATE'S APPROACH TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HAS BEEN A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH.
WHERE MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES
LIKE IMMIGRANTS AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR OFTEN FALL THROUGH THE
CRACKS?
STATE HAS ONE ONGOING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE GRANT PROGRAM CALLED
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM OR DEVELOP.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TEN.
DEVELOPERS AWARDED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN STATE GENERAL
FUNDS ANNUALLY TO THE SAME SET
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SHELTERS.
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE EMERGENCY
SHELTER PLUS THIRTEEN OTHER
PRIESTS PRESCRIBED COURSE
SERVICES.
THERE HAD BEEN NO CHANGES TO
ALLOW FOR NEW AGENCIES.
OR NEW STRATEGIES THAT TARGET
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES OR
FOCUSED ON PREVENTION OR
INNOVATION.
THIS IS WHERE THE CULTURALLY
RESPONSIVE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
NETWORK COMES IN.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS C. R. D. V.
EN.
THIS IS A COLLABORATION FUNDED
BY BLUE SHIELD FOUNDATION OF
SIXTEEN ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
DEVELOPED CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SERVICES.
WITH IN THEIR SPECIFIC
COMMUNITY.
SUCH AS AFRICAN AMERICAN LATINO
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER NATIVE
AMERICAN AND DEATH IN DEAF OR
HARD OF HEARING.
OUR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PROGRAMS
WERE DEVELOPED AT THE GRASSROOTS
LEVEL.
FROM WITH IN OUR SPECIFIC
COMMUNITIES TO SUPPORT OUR DB
SURVIVORS.
WHO WERE NOT GETTING SERVED AS
WELL IN TRADITIONAL MAINSTREAM
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AGENCIES?
THE MAJORITY OF THE C. R. D. V.
EN AGENCIES ARE NOT SHELTER
BASED.
THEREFORE WE DO NOT RECEIVE
DEVELOP FUNDS.
OKAY FAMILY WHICH HAS BEEN
PROVIDING DB SERVICES TO KOREAN
IMMIGRANTS FOR THIRTY FIVE
YEARS.
IT MEANS WE HAVE DEVELOPED HOME
GROWN STRATEGIES THAT WE'VE
FOUND TO BE EFFECTIVE WITHIN OUR
KOREAN COMMUNITY.
SUCH AS ENGAGING KOREAN MEN
EMPLOYEES
FOCUSING ON ARE SURVIVORS
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
AND PARTNERING WITH KOREAN
CHURCHES.
LIKE MANY IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
FAITH BASED INSTITUTIONS ARE
CRITICAL
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE THE
COMMUNITY COMES TOGETHER NOT
JUST FOR SPIRITUAL NEEDS.
BUT TO SHARE INFORMATION AND TO
FIND THEIR COMMUNITY.
WE KNOW THAT SEVENTY TO EIGHTY
PERCENT OF KOREAN IMMIGRANTS
ATTENDED CHURCH REGULARLY.
AND WHEN THERE'S A FAMILY
CRISIS.
OUR COMMUNITY OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WILL GO FIRST
TO THEIR PAST
WHETHER PASTOR'S WIFE'S.
NOT TO A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE EACH.
SO SIX YEARS AGO.
BLUE SHIELD FOUNDATION
GENEROUSLY AWARDED US OUR FIRST
GRANT TO EXPAND OUR WORK WITH
KOREAN CHURCHES.
SINCE THEN WE HAVE TRAINED MORE
THAN A THOUSAND CREATE AMERICAN
FAITH LEADERS.
THROUGH FORTY OUR TRAININGS
TWO DAY OVERNIGHT RID RETREATS
ALL DAY CONFERENCES AND SHORTER
PRESENTATIONS.
WE HAVE AN ADVISORY COUNCIL MADE
UP OF FAITH LEADERS WHO MEET
MONTHLY TO GUIDE OUR WORK.
CO FACILITATOR TRAININGS AND TO
BECOME LEADERS WITHIN THE
CHURCH.
TO END DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
NOW THEY'RE SEEKING MAKE
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES WHEN WE
HAD THAT WE HAD TO OVERCOME TO
BUILD THESE PARTNERSHIPS.
CREATE CHURCHES IN GENERAL HOLD
CONSERVATIVE CHRISTIAN VALUES.
AND FEEL THEIR ROLE IS TO PUT
THE FAMILY FIRST.
WHEREAS IN THE DB FEEL THIS
ISN'T A PROGRESSIVE FEMINIST
BASED MOVEMENT WELL WE PUT THE
SURVIVOR AT THE CENTER.
SO WE HAVE TO DISPEL A LOT OF
THE DISTRESS.
APPROACHING OUR FAITH LEADERS
WITH HUMILITY. AND RESPECT FOR
THE VITAL ROLE THEY PLAY WITH
OUR CREE IN FAMILIES.
THE RESULT IS THAT TRAINED CREAN
FAITH LEADERS. BEGAN TO
RECOGNIZE THE SIGNS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
THEY WERE REFERRING MORE VICTIMS
TO LESS.
AND THEY STARTED PREACHING FROM
THE PULPIT ABOUT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
AND THEIR ATTITUDE BEGAN TO
CHANGE.
WHEREAS THE STARTED OFF BEFORE
THE TRAINING BELIEVING THAT.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND MUST BE
INSURED FOR THE SAKE OF THE
FAMILY.
ONCE THEY GOT TRAINED THEY
REALIZE.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE MUST STOP FOR
THIS.
WE'D LOVE TO SEE THE STATE FIND
NEW CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE
PREVENTION FOCUS PROJECTS LIKE
THIS IN ALL KINDS OF COMMUNITY.
WHICH IS WHY C. R. D. V. EN IS
WORKING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP TO AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
ASK FOR AN ADDITIONAL FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO BE PUT INTO
THE STATE BUDGET TO FIND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT PREVENTION.
AND A WIDE RANGE OF INNOVATIVE
SERVICES TO REACH COMMUNITIES
JUST LIKE OURS.
IT'S TIME FOR THE STATE TO
INVEST IN NEW AND EFFECTIVE
PREVENTION INTERVENTION
APPROACHES
DEVELOPED WITHIN MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES.
CALIFORNIA IS NOW A MAJORITY
MINORITY STATE.
LATINOS ARE THE LARGEST RACIAL
GROUP IN THE STATE AN ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDERS ARE THE
FASTEST GROWING.
BOTH COMMUNITIES HAVE A LARGE
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY.
THAT IS SUBJECT TO ADDITIONAL
LANGUAGE AND CULTURAL BARRIERS.
IT IS ONLY BY CHANGING THE WAY
WE FIND AND PROVIDE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SERVICES.
THAT WE WILL STOP YOU STORIES IN
THISSTATE LIKE THE ONES FROM MY
GRANDMOTHER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HELP WITH
THAT'LL OPEN IT TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
YES.
WELL THE ONE PAGE YOUR NARRATIVE
THAT GREATLY INTERESTS ME ARM.
IN THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES WE
DIDN'T HAVE A SYSTEMATIC
APPROACH TO CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION HEARING CALIFORNIA.
AND PRETTY GROUNDBREAKING
LEGISLATION WHICH THE SIGNED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO I THINK AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY THREE.
COMMITTED TEN MILLION DOLLARS
THAT BILL OR THEY MEDIA
FOLLOWING BILL TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION.
AND THE APPROACH WAS ONE THAT
KIND OF RINGS A BELL FOR ME AS
YOU TALK ABOUT.
WE'VE GOT A STANDARD APPROACH IN
CERTAIN ENTITIES CAN IT THERE'S
NOT MUCH BRANCHING OUT.
BECAUSE THE APPROACH WHEN
CALIFORNIA STARTED
SYSTEMATICALLY MOVING AS CHILD
ABUSE PREVENTION.
AND THESE PROVISIONS NOW IS TWO
FLIES AND OFFER INSTITUTIONS
CODE.
WAS TO LET IN EVERY COUNTY THE
STATE.
ORGANIZED GROUPS TO KIND OF PUT
TOGETHER A PLAN FOR HOW THEY HAD
A VISION OF SOME WAY TO RECTIFY.
AN ASPECT OF CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION.
AND LET IDEAS KIND OF BUBBLE UP
FROM THE BOTTOM AND THEN COMPETE
FOR FUNDING.
AND IT.
ALLOWED FOR ACTUALLY INNOVATION
IN THESE PROGRAMS.
THERE WERE TIED TO THE DISTINCT
PERSPECTIVES OF COMMITTEES FROM
EARTH WHAT WAS HAPPENING.
AND I THINK.
I JUST FEEL THAT'S ACTUALLY VERY
CONSTRUCTIVE.
WAY TO GO ABOUT DOING IT.
I THINK IN THIS AREA. I
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY
FOCUSING UPON YOUR GRANDMOTHER.
BEAUSE I DO THINK A KEY PART OF
THE CHEMISTRY HERE IS SORT OF
THE.
A CULTURAL ENVELOPE PEOPLE RAN.
AND WHAT IS WHAT IS THE CUSTOM
WAY THAT THEY RESPOND TO THINGS
AND WHAT IS.
WHAT HISTORICISM WHAT IS JUST?
TO BE IN DIRT WHATEVER HE HAS.
I THINK FINDING WAYS TO HELP
PEOPLE.
BE EMPOWERED
AND GET OVER SORT OF WHAT THEY
THINK IS.
IS THE ONLY AVAILABLE PATH.
A PATH THEY'RE FAMILIAR WITH
ARAGO THEY'RE MOST COMFORTABLE
WITH SO DESPITE.
WHAT'S BAD THEY DON'T QUITE KNOW
HOW TO FIND A NEW PATH.
.
I KNOW ABOUT THE BILL BECAUSE I
WORKED ON IT.
AND I. HAVE A PRESS RELEASE
SAYING IN MY WALL FROM WHEN IT
WAS SIGNED INTO LAW.
AND THE REASON WE DID THAT WE
SIGNED INTO LAW WAS ACTUALLY
BECAUSE. NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO WAS
A YEAR OF ECONOMIC DOWNTURN.
AND THE GOVERNOR WAS JERRY
BROWN.
AND HE SIGNED THE FUNDING.
DESPITE THE PROSPECT OF A
DOWNTURN.
TO PUT RESOURCES WHERE THEY
WOULD BE VERY MUCH NEEDED.
SIGHS I CAN ASSURE THAT BECAUSE
I THINK THIS IS WHERE THIS TYPE
OF CONVERSATION SHOULD GO.
HOW CAN WE?
FIND THE RIGHT LEVEL OF
RESOURCES PROVIDING THE STATE
LEVEL.
BUT
NOT DICTATE THAT WELL LET'S.
THREE PM ON THURSDAY IN
SACRAMENTO SO THE PROGRAMS ARE
RUNNING THIS WAY AND ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES.
TO FIND A WAY TO KIND OF PUT.
PUT FINDING OUT WHERE PEOPLE WHO
ARE CLOSE TO THE. SCENE.
I SEE THE PROBLEMS
SHE THE MANIFESTATIONS THAT THEY
NEED TO CONFRONT. CAN KIND OF
INVASION NEW APPROACHES AND THEN
STE SHARE SOME FUNDING STREAM.
I THINK THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY AND
ANYONE ELSE.
I'M GOING TO.
IT QUICKLY.
.
THE PROGRAM THAT YOU CURRENTLY
INVOLVED IN ITS IT FUND WHAT WHO
THE THUNDER THROUGH.
SO OUR WORK WITH FAITH BASED
LEADERS IS CURRENTLY FUNDED
THROUGH BLUE SHIELD FOUNDATION
OKAY I DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PROGRAM
WHICH HAS MULTIFACETED FUNDED.
BY PRIVATE FOUNDATIONS AS WELL
AS GOVERNMENT FUND IT'S FOUND
WHERE IN THE STATE IT'S IN
KOREATOWN IN LOS ANGELES SO IT'S
SICK REPEAT LOCATED IN LA WE ARE
SPECIFICALLY LOOKING LA AND WE
WORK WITH.
SCREEN AMERICANS THROUGHOUT THE
GREATER LOS ANGELES AREA WHICH
INCLUDES THE FIVE COUNTIES.
OKAY RIGHT. ONE OF THE I THINK
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES AND I
GUESS WE'LL WE'LL FIGURE THAT
OUT IS THAT.
THEIR* OUT.
NOW THAT THEY'RE ALL EFFECTIVE
THERE SO MANY DIFFERENT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE PROGRAMS FUNDED BY SO
MANY DIFFERENT SOURCES. AND EVEN
SOME OF.
IN THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES HERE AND SOME DIFFERENT
PLACES SO IT'S LIKE.
IT'S IT'S SO BROAD IN TERMS OF
THE PROGRAMS IN THE FUNDING IT'S
HARD TO WRAP YOUR HAND AROUND
WHAT THE STATE NEEDS TO DO
BECAUSE OF SO MANY PIECES THAT
ARE MOVING.
AND.
AND I KNOW THAT OUR. OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES HAS SEVERAL
DIFFERENT PIECES AS WELL SO IT
BECOMES IT BECOMES A DIFFICULT
ISSUE NOT THAT WE SHOULDN'T
GRAPPLE WITH THE BUT OFTENTIMES
IT COMES. RATHER QUICKLY AND.
AND THE ABILITY TO BASICALLY
COORDINATE IN SOME WAY BUILD
LEVEL FUNDING TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU'VE COVERED EVERY AREA. YOU
KNOW EVERY CITY HAS A DIFFERENT
KIND OF PROGRAM AND. KNOW SAN
DIEGO HAS SEVERAL ITSELF
WOULDN'T IN TERMS OF SHELTERS
AND I'VE BEEN ON SEVERAL BOARDS
SO IT IT'S.
.
AT THIS LEVEL IT'S KIND OF HARD
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT YOU DOING YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU WHEN YOU HAVE TEN
MILLION TWENTY MILLION FIFTY
MILLION WHATEVER IT IS. IT'S
HARD TO FIGURE OUT WHERE IT
NEEDS TO GO.
AND WHETHER NOT WHERE IT'S
GOING IS GOING TO BE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY BECAUSE OFTENTIMES
SQUEAKY WHEEL GETS THE OIL. BUT
IT MAY NOT BE THE MOST NECESSARY
PLACE AND SO I THINK AT SOME
POINT AND MAYBE THIS COMMITTEE
WILL DEAL WITH THAT.
THE.
THE VARYING NEEDS AND HOW IT'S
ACTUALLY COORDINATED NAM AND
LOOKED AT NO WE'VE ASKED THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES TO
LOOK AT IT.
BECAUSE THIS A LOT OF STUFF
BEING PUT IN THAT.
OUR OFFICE THAT RELATES TO THIS
AREA AND SO UP.
I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
WHICH I YOU KNOW I KNOW THERE
ARE LOT OF OTHER. ETHNIC GROUPS
ARE ALSO GRAPPLING WITH THE
THING BECAUSE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
IS A UP.
IS A VERY.
OF BE YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S A
SITUATION THAT IS IS NOT ONLY
IMPACTED BY ALL THE OTHER THINGS
BUT IT'S ALSO GREATLY IMPACTED
BY CULTURE.
AND WHAT WOULD GROUPS DO AND
DON'T DO YOU KNOW AND SO WHEN
YOU LOOK AT IT.
.
I KNOW AGES AGO WHEN I WAS ON
THE BOARD WHEN THEY START
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN SAN DIEGO'S
ON THE REGIONAL BOARD AT THE WHY
AND FOR. AND IT WAS INTERESTING
THAT EVEN THOUGH THE THE
DIRECTOR WAS AFRICAN AMERICAN.
THERE WERE NO AFRICAN AMERICANS
IN THE PROGRAM.
NONE WELL WHERE IN THE CENTERS
AND WHAT HAVE YOU SO THE
ASSUMPTION WAS THAT THERE WASN'T
THAT MUCH DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN
BLACK COMMUNITIES. BECAUSE BLACK
WOMEN GOT IT UNDER CONTROL AND
NOBODY HITS THEM LIKE I GOT HIT
BACK. A MINUTE WAS JILL THINKING
SO IT DOES RESULT YOU KNOW HOPE
THAT THERE WASN'T A LOT OF
SERVICES THERE BUT THERE WAS
ALSO A CONCERN THAT.
A WHEN YOU CALL THE POLICE IN
THE BLACK COMMUNITY YOU YOU GET
WORSE SITUATIONS REVENUE BETTER
SITUATION SO IS A YOU MAY CALL
OF THE MEN GET SHOT FOR DOING
LITTLE OR NOTHING SO. AS A
RESULT COMMUNITIES WERE NOT
WILLING TO ALWAYS OPEN UP AND
CALL POLICE OFFICER BECAME
REALLY DIFFICULT OUGHT TO DEAL
WITH THOSE ISSUES IN A CULTURAL
WAY SO.
YOU KNOW SO IT WOULD BE
INTERESTING.
AS THOSE GROUPS DEVELOP YOU
KNOW THAT THEY ISSUE OF CULTURE
BECAME EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
SHOULD BE BECAUSE LOOK AT IN SO
MANY DIFFERENT WAYS AND AND SO
MANY CULTURAL NORMS WHAT
FAMILIES DO AND DON'T DO AND.
AND HOW THE LARGER SOCIETY
INTERACTS WITH THEM HAS. A
PROFOUND IMPACT ON ON WHAT'S
TAKING PLACE AND SO ON. A BUT I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS A YOU
KNOW A AND AND I KNOW THAT WE
HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO. IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THIS BIG PICTURE LOOKS LIKE
AND HOPEFULLY ACTS OF THIS
COMMITTEE MIGHT BE ABLE TO.
RAPIDS ARM AROUND AND GIVE SOME
GUIDANCE
I THINK A BIG CAPITAL AND SOME
GUIDANCE TO OUR. OF FUNDING
PROCESS AND WHAT HAVE YOU IN
TERMS OF SO WE HAVE SOME SITES
SUMS SUMS.
CERTAINTY AND WHEN WE DEAL WITH
IT THAT WE ARE REALLY
APPROPRIATELY ADDRESSING THE
ISSUES THAT ARE OUT THERE AND
THAT WE'VE GOT ALL THE ISSUES
COVERED. YEAH.
YEAH MAY I RESPOND TO HIM.
IT'S SO I CAN ONE OF THE THINGS
ABOUT THE FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET ASK FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND SEXUAL ASSAULT IS THAT IT
HAS BEEN.
REQUESTED THAT SIXTY PERCENT OF
THAT FUNDING GO TO PREVENTION
FORTY PERCENT UP TO MEET THIRTY
PERCENT FOR. A NEW STRATEGIES
AND TEN PERCENT FOR EVALUATION.
AND WITH IN THAT STRUCTURE
THERE'S ALSO BEEN AN EMPHASIS
THAT NEW FUNDING NEEDS TO GO TO
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE SERVICE
SAYS SO. I THINK THERE ARE SOME
FRAMEWORK.
BEING WORKED OUT WHERE SEE OUR
DD AND FEELS VERY STRONGLY THAT
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE HAS TO GO
IN EACH OF THOSE AREAS
PREVENTION IN.
INTERVENTION AND EVALUATION AND
TO GO BACK TO YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOLIES POINT WHEN YOU
MENTION I THINK THE I THINK IT'S
A VERY ASTUTE. OBSERVATION YOU
MADE AND AND YOU'RE AND I THANK
YOU FOR THE EXPLANATION. AND YOU
MENTIONED HOW COMMUNITIES DID IT
FROM THE BOTTOM UP APPROACH AND
I THINK THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE A VERY.
SCHOOL RIDE SYSTEM THAT SAYS
FOURTEEN.
ABOUT WE DON'T CALL IT BOTTOM UP
WE CALL IT MARCHING TO CENTER
BUT IT'S THE SAME IDEA LET'S
LOOK AT WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
MARGINALIZED WHAT HAD THEY DONE
THAT'S BEEN EFFECTIVE. AND LET'S
BRING THAT AND BRING THAT INTO
THE MIX OF SERVICES AND PROGRAMS
THAT WERE OFFERING IN THIS STATE
BECAUSE.
THE CURRENT MODEL IS.
MEN IT'S HE'S NOT MAN BATTERERS
ARE TAKING AWAY INCARCERATED AND
SURVIVORS ARE USUALLY GOING INTO
SHELTER AND OUR SYSTEM IS VERY
MUCH FOCUSED ON THE CRISIS WE
HAVE HOT LIKE WE HAVE SHELTER
BUT. AND IT'S SHELTERS ARE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT WE'VE
ALWAYS HAD NEED THEM AND THAT
TWENTY A MILLION DOLLARS WAS FOR
THAT. BUT WHAT WE'RE MISSING IS
WORSE THE PREVENTION RECEIPT
EARLY INTERVENTION WHERE IS THE
WORK THAT SAYS.
SOME COMMUNITY SAY I DON'T WANT.
TO SEPARATE AND SO WHAT CAN WE
STILL DO TO ADDRESS DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE EVEN IN SITUATIONS
WHERE THE FAMILIES DON'T WANNA
BE SEPARATED.
BECAUSE WHAT I'VE SEEN IN OUR
COMMUNITY IS THAT BY THE TIME
KOREAN CLIENTS ARE WILLING TO GO
INTO A SHELTER. IT'S REACHED A
CRISIS
IT'S IT HAS REACHED A POINT
WHERE USUALLY THE WOMEN ARE
SAYING.
MY GOD I'M GONNA DIE IF I DON'T
LEAVE AN ESCAPE NOW AND WHY ARE
WE NOT ADDRESSING IT IN AN
EARLIER POINT BEFORE IT GETS
THERE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
WELL I'M THE COMMENT THAT I
DON'T WANT TO MAKE IS IS INTO
YOU KNOW I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE CULTURALLY
RESPONSIVE.
APPROACH ESPECIALLY NOW IN A
SITUATION WHERE WE HAVE A LOT OF
THE LEAD THE IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY
NOT A SILLY LOOKING.
AYE UNFORTUNATELY THE MAJORITY
ARE LATINO BUT I KNOW THAT
THERE'S OTHER IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE DEALING
WITH THIS I'VE BEEN IN
SITUATIONS WHERE THEY'RE LIKE.
.
IF IF YOU GO IN REPORT I'M GOING
CALL OUR IMMIGRATION ON YOU.
AND AND.
THAT'S A BIG ISSUE THAT'S BEEN
BROUGHT UP AGAIN BECAUSE OF THE
CURRENT SITUATION THAT WE HAVE
WITH THE WITH OUR PRESIDENT THAT
YOU KNOW THAT THE. IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES ARE BEING TARGETED
BUT MORE THAN THAT I THINK.
.
THE ISSUE OF POVERTY EVEN THOUGH
IT'S NOT A PRETTY PARTICULAR
CALLED IT IS A CULTURE WITHIN
ITSELF THAT THE ISSUE OF POVERTY
IS SO HUGE THAT A LOT OF THESE.
FAMILIES LIKE YOU SAY THEY
DON'T WANT TO BE SEPARATED BUT
MORE THAN THAT WHAT DO THEY DO
BECAUSE THEY'RE.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE IN A WORSE
SITUATION THAT THEY ARE NOW AND
SO CULTURAL YES YOU KNOW
ETHNICALLY OF CULTURAL BUT I
THINK POVERTY IS IT BECOMING A
CULTURE.
WHERE WHERE? WE'RE NEEDING THE
HELP AND SO IF YOU CAN HELP US
WITH THOSE CHARGES BUT I'M I'M
STE I'M HAPPY THAT WE HAVE.
HAVE YOU NOW BUT I'M SADDENED
THAT THAT'S THE ONLY AT LEAST
FOR NOW THE PROGRAM THAT WE KNOW
OF BECAUSE. BAD APPROACH NEEDS
TO BE IN EVERY COMMUNITY I KNOW
YOU NOW THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES ARE VERY FACEPLATE
THINK FAITH BASED.
THE LATINO COMMUNITY THERE YOU
KNOW AND I SEE THOSE BECAUSE
THOSE ARE THE HIGHEST
PERCENTAGES OF OF.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE INCIDENTS BUT
WE WE HAVE THE ABILITY THROUGH.
CHURCHES TO GET THIS
INFORMATION OUT AND SELF VIEW
COULD.
NOT MY ASK OF YOU IS YOU KNOW
SEND US THE MODEL THE PROGRAM
AYE SO THAT WE DON'T REINVENT
THE WHEEL AND WE HAVE ACCESS TO
THAT. SO THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THESE BUDGET.
REQUESTS THAT WE HAVE SOMETHING
SOLID.
AND SOME DATA AS TO HOW
EFFECTIVE IT IS SO THAT THE NEXT
YEAR AND HOPEFULLY THIS YEAR AND
THINKING I WANT TO THANK DOCTOR
WEBER FOR SUPPORTING OUR OUR
OUR.
OUR BECAUSE.
BITE IN THE IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S
NOT GOING TO BE JUST THIS YEAR
AND I THINK THAT WE NEED TO KEEP
LOOKING AT THIS AND A YEARLY
BASIS AND IF WE CAN HAVE. THAT
DATA AVAILABLE IT WOULD HELP US
BRING THE DATA TO THE TABLE TO
SEE HOW EFFECTIVE THAT FUNDING
HAS BEEN AND SO. THAT WE KNOW
THAT IT'S NOT AN AND TODAY WE
KNOW THAT WE'RE NOT CAN GOING TO
ERADICATE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE BUT
IF WE KEEP INVESTING IN THIS.
THEN THE HOPE IS THAT EVENTUALLY
WE CAN BUT ONLY THROUGH DATA
UNFORTUNATELY FOR US UP HERE WE
ONLY SEE YOU.
THE BIG PICTURE WE DON'T HAVE
THE ACCESS THAT YOU DO TO THE
GROUND YOU KNOW THE BOOTS ON THE
GROUND IF YOU WILL.
TO HELP US THROUGH THIS
SOMETIMES WERE CAUGHT UP IN THIS
YOU KNOW A FI LOW UP HERE ABOUT
LOOKING AT IT AS A LINE ITEM AS
OPPOSED TO.
WHAT PROGRAMS WORK AND WHAT IS
EFFECTIVE SO I LIVE THAT'S MY
ASKED OF YOU AND IF ANYBODY ELSE
HAS ANY MORE QUESTIONS I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
AND?
YOU KNOW IT'S VERY.
DIFFERENT TO HERE PERSONAL
TESTIMONY THAN IT IS TO READ
ABOUT IT AND SO I THINK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO DO THAT.
HELP US BE EDUCATED IN THIS
ISSUE SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND I OF THE FORTY
SHARING THAT INFORMATION WITH
YOU SOME GREAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
I'D NEXT I WANT TO CALL.
KAREN EARL EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF.
JEALOUSY.
IN ITS I DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
HELP KILLER PARTNERSHIP IS A
TOPIC THAT WILL BE DISCUSSING
NEXT.
I WANT TO SAY I AM VERY HONORED
TO BE HERE TODAY AND FOR ME IT'S
A FULL CIRCLE MOMENT. TESTIFYING
IN FRONT OF YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO IS A FOURTEENTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT IN OTHER. AWESOME.
MEMBERS OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AS WE
DISCUSS INNOVATIVE APPROACHES TO
ADDRESSING THAT PREVENTING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR I SERVED
AS CHIEF OF STAFF TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MARGUERITE ARCHIE HUDSON
ALSO A THE FOURTEENTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT. DURING THE TIME OF THE
OJ SIMPSON TRIAL AND IF THERE
WERE HASH TAGS DURING THAT
PERIOD. FOR ME IT WOULD BE HASH
TAG BEGINNING OF THE PRE WOKE
MODE MOVEMENT. I SAY PRE WOKE
BECAUSE MANY PEOPLE WANTED TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE INCLUDING WITH
THE GROUND BREAKING VIOLENCE
AGAINST WOMEN ACT AND SO MANY
PEOPLE DID. MAKE A DIFFERENCE
BUT BECAUSE MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES AND WOMEN OF COLOR
WERE NOT AT THE STRATEGY TABLE
AND PROMINENTLY HEARD. ISSUES
IMPACTING MANY OF THESE
COMMUNITIES WERE NOT ADDRESSED
AND TO THIS DAY WE CONTINUE TO
PLAY CATCH UP.
I REMEMBER THE STRUGGLE TO
RECTIFY IN CHANGE THE FORMULA
THAT WAS USED TO DISTRIBUTE
NONCOMPETITIVE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE GRANTS AND THE FIGHT
WAGE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. ARCHIE
HUDSON BARBARA LEE AND SPEAKER
WILLIE BROWN WHO CAME TOGETHER
TO TRY TO MAKE AN IMPACT.
IT WAS TOO LITTLE TOO LATE.
SOME SERVICE PROVIDERS RECEIVED
NONCOMPETITIVE GRATZ OF HALF
MILLION DOLLARS WILD FOR EXAMPLE
GENOCIDE RECEIVED FIFTY
THOUSAND.
CLEARLY I'VE NEVER FORGOTTEN
THAT TIME IN HISTORY AND I
UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGING ROAD
IT HAS BEEN FOR ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE TENNESSEE TO EFFECTIVELY
SERVE WITH FEWER RESOURCES.
CLIENTS WHO PRESENT WITH THE
MOST COMPLEX SET OF ISSUES
OF COURSE THESE ARE DIFFICULT
CONVERSATIONS TO HAVE BUT
NECESSARY AND ONE OF THE MANY
REASONS I'M HAPPY TO STILL HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO THIS WORK
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AND TO SEE
FULL CIRCLE MOMENTS THAT INCLUDE
THE CURRENT CREATION OF COLD
HEARTS.
AND NETWORKS.
AND COALITIONS THAT ARE
GENUINELY INCLUSIVE. AND ENABLE
ALL VOICES AND PERSPECTIVES TO
BE HEARD AND THAT'S WHY
PARTICULARLY PROUD TO BE PART OF
THE CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE
DOMESTIC BALLOTS NETWORK.
OUR STORY WHEN JESSE WAS FOUNDED
SOME THIRTY EIGHT YEARS AGO BY
FIVE WOMEN FROM THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WAS CONSIDERED TABOO.
A PRIVATE MATTER TO BE RESOLVED
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS GENESIS
FOUNDERS.
HELP CHANGE THAT BY PUTTING
GENDER BASED VIOLENCE AND THE
NEED FOR CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE
SERVICES FRONT AND CENTER IN
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH.
STILL SALUTE SOCIAL JUSTICE AND
HEALTH DISPARITIES.
THE LEGACY OF GENESIS FOUNDERS
IS AN ORGANIZATION THAT
CONSISTENTLY STRIVES
TO BE INCLUSIVE IN TERMS OF
DIVERSITY AND LIFE EXPERIENCES.
JESSE RECRUITS BOARD AND STAFF
MEMBERS WHO ARE DEVOTED TO THIS
BECAUSE IN WHO SHARED
EXPERIENCES HELP FACILITATE
TRUSTING RELATIONSHIPS WITHIN
THE ORGANIZATIONS AND IN THE
COMMUNITIES WE SERVE.
TRUE TO GENESIS STANCE THAT
MINUTE MAN MUST BE INVOLVED IN
FINDING A SOLUTION TO GENOM BASE
VIOLENCE GENESIS ENGAGES MAN ON
ITS BOARD STAFF IN AS
VOLUNTEERS.
JESSE'S VOLUNTEERS AND YOU'VE
PARTICIPATING A PREVENTION
PROGRAMS GENERATION JAY AND
OTHER YOUTH PROGRAMS WORK TO
BRING DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES TO
GENESIS APPROACH.
TODAY GENESIS MULTICULTURAL
STAFF AND VOLUNTEERS PROVIDE A
CONTINUUM OF SERVICES TWENTY
FOUR HOURS A DAY. THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE DAYS A YEAR AND
INCLUDE EMERGENCY SHELTER
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING DIRECT
SERVICES AND OUTREACH AND
PREVENTION STRATEGIES.
JESSE IMPLEMENTS DOZENS OF
CULTURALLY COMPETENT AND
INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
EACH YEAR IN USES COMMUNITY
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION TO CHIRP
TRANSFORM. PUBLIC PERCEPTION AS
IT RELATES TO DOMESTIC
INTERPERSONAL AND COMMUNITY
VIOLENCE
MANY OF GENESIS PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES INCLUDING GENESIS AWARD
WINNING LEGAL PROGRAMS WERE
ESTABLISHED. AS AN ORGANIC
RESPONSE TO OUR CLIENTS NEEDS.
FOR EXAMPLE SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY NINE BEFORE THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN ESCAPING.
X. GAPING CYCLIC VIOLENCE AND
ACCESS TO LEGAL ASSISTANT WAS
FULLY UNDERSTOOD TENNESSEE HAS
PROVIDED DIRECTLY LEGAL SERVICES
AT NO CHARGE TO SURVIVING.
SURVIVORS STRUGGLING THROUGH
MYRIAD LEGAL ISSUES.
AND JEALOUSY OUR CLIENTS
REPRESENTS SOME OF THE MOST
MARVELOUS MARGINALIZE SEGMENT OF
SOCIETY WHO ARE PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE JESSE BRINGS RESOURCE
SYSTEM UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
THROUGH INNOVATION. AND
STRATEGIC PARTNERSHIPS ALLOWING
US TO MAXIMIZE RESOURCES.
THIS VAST MAJORITY THE VAST
MAJORITY IF NOT ALL OF GENESIS
CLIENTS ARE FROM FAMILIES THAT
HAVE BEEN LOCKED IN
INTERGENERATIONAL CYCLES OF
POVERTY. PREVENTED FROM
REALIZING THE DIGNITIES AND
LIBERTIES THAT THEY DESERVE
BECAUSE OF THE ZIP CODES IN
WHICH THEY WERE BORN AND THE
SYSTEMIC INEQUITY IN TERMS OF
EDUCATION. INCOME OPPORTUNITIES
THAT A WRAP IT IN THOSE AREAS.
CLEARLY WE NEEDED TO CREATE A
PROGRAM THAT GOES BEYOND THE.
USUAL HOTLINE IN TAKE SHELTER
FOOD FEEL BETTER EXIT RETURNED
TO PREVIOUS LIFE MORE VIOLENCE
HOTLINE IN TAKE SHELTER FOOD.
BILL BETTER EXIT AND REPEAT
WE NEEDED TO PROVIDE.
TIME AND SPACE FOR SURVIVORS TO
HEAL.
TOO INC TO ACHIEVE THIS GOAL WE
NEEDED TO LISTEN TO THE DATA.
THE DATA IS AT THE CENTER OF OUR
PROGRAM DESIGN WHEN WE SAY
LISTEN TO THE DATA WE MEAN IT'S
NECESSARY TO GO BEYOND
COLLECTING NUMBERS BUT THERE IS
ALSO A VERY REAL RESPONSIBILITY.
TO UTILIZE THE INFORMATION TO
ENSURE FAMILIES WHO INTO
JEALOUSY CAN BECOME SUCCESSFUL.
FOR EXAMPLE DATA FROM A RECENT.
SURVEY NOTED THAT IN NINETEEN
NOT THAT I'M SORRY IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SIX WOMEN WHO ENTERED THE
SHELTER SUFFER CHRONIC HEALTH
CONDITIONS.
EIGHTEEN HAD BEEN KIDNAPPED
FORTY NINE WERE SURVIVORS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING FIFTY SIX WERE
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED HIS CHILDREN
SIXTEEN WHERE IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM AND THE LIST GOES ON.
WITH WOMEN AND THEIR CHILDREN
PRESENTING WITH THESE ISSUES
IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO ONLY FOCUS ON
SHELTER FOOD FEELING BETTER.
ALTHOUGH VERY IMPORTANT THIS IS
A START IF WE ARE TO TRULY
CHANGE THE TRAJECTORY OF THESE
FAMILIES IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE
ENGAGE IN SIGNIFICANT
PARTNERSHIPS THAT GO BEYOND THE
USUAL. IT'S ALSO IT'S ALWAYS
BEEN CLEAR TO ME
SO WHEN WE MEET PARTNERS LIKE
BLUE SHIELD FOUNDATION WHO
UNDERSTAND THIS LAYER ISSUE WE
BEGAN TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCES IN OUR COMMUNITY.
THE BEAUTY IS THAT
THE FOUNDATION GOES BEYOND JUST
UNDERSTANDING BUT THEY ALSO
SUPPORT AND HELP TO IMPLEMENT
STRATEGIES BECAUSE THEY TOO ARE
LISTENING TO THE DATA.
BLUE SHIELD UNDERWROTE THE
GENESIS CENTER WHAT'S HEALTH
CARE PARTNERSHIP IN ACCORDING TO
DOCTOR DAEDRA LONG OBGYN AT
WHAT'S BEFORE THE PARTNERSHIP IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN NINETY SIX WOMEN
WERE SCREEN FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. AND BECAUSE OF THE
PARTNERSHIP IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
FIVE HUNDRED AND FIVE PATIENTS
WERE SCREEN AND WHAT'S HAD A
PLACE TO REFER THEM GENESIS
CENTER.
THESE PROP PARTNERSHIPS PROVIDE
ACCESS TO SERVICES MANY TIMES
LIFE CHANGING SERVICES ONE OF
OUR MIRACLES HAPPEN WHEN A
FAMILY CAME INTO A SHELTER.
BECAUSE A RIFF FROM A REFILL OUR
REFERRAL FROM A SCHOOL WHERE WE
WORK ON PREVENTION PROGRAMS.
WHILE IN THE SHELTER AND THROUGH
A HEALTH ASSESSMENT WE
DISCOVERED THAT THE MOM HAD
CANCER NO ONE IS THINKING ABOUT
THEIR
ACHES AND PAINS. AND THAT'S
SOMETHING BIGGER MIGHT BE WRONG
IT TOOK THE QUIET SPACE OF A
SHELTER FOR THE MOM TO RECEIVE
THE DIAGNOSES AND BECAUSE OF
PARTNERSHIPS WE WERE ABLE TO
COORDINATE CARE WITH WHAT'S
HEALTH CARE.
THE QUESTION BECOMES
HOW DO WE MAKE THESE
PARTNERSHIPS AND COLLABORATIONS
PART OF THE INSTITUTIONAL.
INFRASTRUCTURE OF ORGANIZATIONS
AND NOT EPISODIC OR PASSION
PROJECT OF INDIVIDUAL EMPLOYEES
MANAGEMENT OUR CURRENT
LEADERSHIP. BLUESHIELD
FOUNDATION IS BLAZING THE
FOUNDATION IN THIS REGARD. WE'RE
GRATEFUL TO BLUESHIELD
FOUNDATION FOR WORKING WITH
GENESIS CENTER THE EAST LOS
ANGELES WOMEN'S CENTER YWCA SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY. AND COMMUNITY
LEGAL SERVICES IN SOUTH EAST LOS
ANGELES TO INSTITUTIONALIZE
THESE PROGRAMS THE POLICY AND
PROCEDURE THEIR INVESTMENT IN
THIS WORK ISN'T EBELING US TO
PROMOTE THE IMPORTANCE OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. AND HEALTH
CARE PARTNERSHIP.
I'M HONORED THAT TENNESSEE HAS
THREE PHYSICIANS ON OUR BOARD
TOOL OF HOME ARE BUT DID UP
PEDIATRICIANS BAKED TO
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
THESE IN A. FADED AND
INTERSECTIONAL PARTNERSHIP.
I QUOTE DOCTOR SYLVIA SWILLY
JEALOUSY BORED ME MEMBER AND
PEDIATRICIAN.
TRAUMA PHYSICAL IN MOTION
UNEMOTIONAL.
INFLICTED BY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
HAS BEEN SHOWN TO ADVERSELY
AFFECT LONG TERM MEDICAL
OUTCOMES
DEPRESSION AND UP UP.
BOB B. CITY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SHOULD BE VIEWED AS A MEDICAL
PROBLEM THE CHILDREN WHO HAVE
THREE OR MORE ADVERSE EXPERIENCE
AND CERTAINLY OUR CLIENTS.
WHO HAVE THREE A MORE?
CHILD EXPERIENCE AND CERTAINLY
OUR CLIENTS WERE CHILDREN MEET
THIS CRITERIA ARE KNOWN TO HAVE
NEGATIVE LONG TERM HEALTH
OUTCOMES AS RELATES TO HEART
DISEASE ASTHMA A BE CITY
SUICIDE.
AND THIS HAS BEEN REFERENCE IN
MEDICAL JOURNALS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE NEGATIVELY
AFFECTS HEALTHCARE. COSTS.
IN A QUOTE. ROBUST MEANINGFUL
PARTNERSHIPS LIKE THE ONE WE
SHARE WITH BLUE CHAU FOUNDATION
ENABLES US TO GO BEYOND RHETORIC
AND FEEL GOOD PHILANTHROPY TO
MAKE REAL LASTING CHANGE IN THE
COMMUNITIES WE SERVE. AND MAKE
IT POSSIBLE FOR US TO DREAM OF A
WORLD IN WHICH GENDER BASED
VIOLENCE IS A THING OF THE PAST.
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'LL BRING
UP TO THE COMMITTEE IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISSOURI I'M
CERTAINLY.
APPRECIATE IN GENESIS HAS BEEN
OVER A LONG STANDING
ORGANIZATION THE COMMUNITY.
I REMEMBER WHAT I WAS THE CHAIR
OF THE COMMITTEE ACTS WERE FOR
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES AND
HOW. PLEASED TO FIND YOU
ORGANIZATION TERMS OF THE WORK
THAT YOU DO IN THE COMMUNITY.
I'M CERTAINLY AT MY TAKE AWAY AS
THE PARTNERSHIP IS A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT.
AND TRYING TO PROVIDE A LINKAGE.
IN THE COMMUNITY SPECIAL
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS IN
THE COMMUNITY TO TRY TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE SYSTEMIC ISSUES THAT
EXISTS. AND SO.
AS WELL LET YOU KNOW THAT
CERTAINLY WE STAND READY WILLING
ABLE TO DO WHATEVER THEY HAVE TO
LIFT AND WE NEED.
TO DO TO TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT
COME TO FOR RATIONS.
BECAUSE AGAIN I'M A FIRM
BELIEVER THE MEDIA'S TAYLOE
STORY ABOUT MY MOM AND MY SISTER
WAS.
DATING THIS IS GENTLEMAN.
SEE RATHER THUNDER THINKS IS A
BLACK WOMAN FROM THE SOUTH.
SO SHE TOLD BUSES BOYFRIEND
PLEASE COME INTO A ROOM TO SIT
ON HER BED WITH THEIR AND SHE
TOOK MY SISTERS ARE YOU SEE THAT
FACE.
TURNED BOTH SIDES HERE ARMS
THAT'STHE WAY I WANT TO COME
HOME EVERY TIME YEAH.
IF NOT OPEN A CLOSET UP RIGHT
THERE.
AND SO SHE SAID LOVE XIN NEVER
HURT.
LOVE SHOULDN'T HURT.
AS IF TO GIVE TO GET TO A POINT
WALK AWAY.
WALK AWAY THAT'S THE BEST THING
FOR YOU GO COUNTERTENOR GO OUT
FOR A WALK AROUND THE CORNER THE
LOVE SCENE NEVER HURT.
AND SO THAT WAS CERTAINLY A TAKE
AWAY FROM ME AND I KNOW THE WORK
THAT YOU GUYS DO I'M IN YOUR
KIT.
AT THE GENESIS CENTER.
TRAINING OUR YOUNG MALES
SO THEY CAN GROW UP TO
UNDERSTAND THE LOVE SHOULDN'T
HURT.
AND I BELIEVE AGAIN TRAIN UP A
CHILD IN THE WAY HERE SEIZE AGO
WHEN A GHETTO THEY WILL NOT
DEPART.
AND ALSO IN THE AFRICA IN A
POVERTY IT TAKES ENTIRE VILLAGE
WHO WE HAVE TO AS LAWMAKERS
PROVIDE RESOURCES FOR THE
VILLAGE YEAH WE CANNOT EXPECT
SPEC THE VILLAGE OPERATE. AND TO
RAISE A CHILD IF THERE'S NO
RESOURCES THERE.
AND SO WE HAVE TO BE A STRONG
ADVOCATE AND CERTAINLY.
YOU KNOWS MY DESIRES TO PRESS
ONE EVERYONE THIS ROOM TO BE A
STRONG ADVOCATE TO ADVOCATE FOR
THE CHANGE YOU WANT TO SEE BUT
ALSO MAKING SURE THAT YOUR
PRESENCE. IS MAY KNOWN APPEARED
SACRAMENTO'S LAWMAKERS.
SO GET OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF YOUR COMMITMENT TO THE
COMMUNITY AND ALSO A IN THIS
SPACE AROUND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE A
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THIS COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU I'M JUST
JUST ANOTHER COMMENT.
AND I'M SEEING IT WE HAVE
DIFFERENT A LOT OF DIFFERENT A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT THAT I DO THIS WORK AND HE
AND I DON'T WANT TO FEEL LIKE I
AM IGNORANT. BUT THERE'S SO MANY
THAT WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT AND I
THINK THAT'S.
HOPEFULLY THIS IS WHAT WOULD BE
ONE OF THE TAKE AWAYS IS HOW
MANY.
ORGANIZATIONS AND DO WE HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE LIST OF HOW MANY
ORGANIZATIONS ARE SUPPORTING THE
COMMUNITIES SO THAT OUR OFFICES
NOT JUST APPEAR BUT THE OFFICES
IN THE COULD I. IN OUR DISTRICT
OFFICES HANDLES RESOURCES
AVAILABLE I KNOW.
MY STAFF IS
WELL BETTER PREPARED THAN I AM.
BUT I KNOW THAT YOU KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE I DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT THE
KOREAN.
ORGANIZATION I DIDN'T
NECESSARILY KNOW ABOUT YOU.
AND SO I WANT AT THIS TO ALSO BE
WHERE WE COMPILE THE DIFFERENT
AGENCIES IN DIFFERENT COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE DOING
THIS WORK SO THAT WE CAN NOT
ONLY REACH OUT TO YOU BUT WHEN
THERE'S A CRISIS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WE. ARE ABLE TO
REFER THEM TO.
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE YOU SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT INFORMATION I'M
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ELOISE GOMEZ
REYES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF THANK YOU
FOR FOR THE INFORMATION YOU
IT'S IT IS SO IMPORTANT I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF OF MY
COLLEAGUES.
I KNOW THAT IN SAN BERNADINE ON
OUR AREA WE MADE IT A POINT TO
IT JUST AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
HAS DONE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR STAFF
KNOWS WOULDN'T WE RECEIVE A CALL
WE NEED TO KNOW WHO TO REFER
PEOPLE TO.
I APPRECIATE THE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES THAT YOU'VE TALKED
ABOUT.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT LEGAL
SERVICES YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
EVEN THOUGH IT WAS A STAR CYCLE.
YOU KNEW WHERE TO PUT EACH
PERSON TO PROVIDE THAT
ASSISTANCE BUT
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU ALSO
PROVIDED THAT LEGAL ASSISTANCE
SO THAT THEY COULD SEE THAT
THERE WAS AN OPTION.
WE WE WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH
FOR INSTANCE ONE OF THE THE
PLACES IT'S TIME FOR CHANGE
FOUNDATION.
FOR THE FORMERLY INCARCERATED.
MANY OF THOSE WERE FORMALLY
INCARCERATED ALSO WORTH VICTIMS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
AND SO THIS THIS
INTERGENERATIONAL.
ASPECT THAT YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT
IF SOMETHING WE DO HAVE TO FIND
A WAY TO TO TO.
STOP IT TO CUT IT.
ONE OF THINGS THAT THAT FOR ME
HAS BEEN SO IMPORTANT IS THAT
WHEN WE START PUTTING TOGETHER
THE BUDGET THAT WE COME UP WITH
THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. AND IT
GOES TO AN ORGANIZATION
OFTENTIMES THE ORGANIZATION
STATE OF.
FUNNELING IT TO THE VERY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE DOING THE
WORK IN THE COMMUNITY THEY START
BRINGING PEOPLE FROM OUTSIDE THE
COMMUNITY TO COME IN AND STUDY
THE ISSUE.
WE DON'T NEED STUDIES
WE HAVE ORGANIZATIONS LIKE YOURS
LIKE YOURS. THAT ARE ALREADY
DOING THE WORK AND THE WEEK WE
DON'T WHAT YOU TALKED ABOUT WE
DON'T HAVE TO REINVENT THE WHEEL
WE LOOK TO THE SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAMS.
AND YOURS OF THE PROGRAM'S.
THAT THAT THAT WE NEED TO THEM
FIVE WE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
FUNDING FINDS ITS WAY TO YOU.
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE ABLE TO SERVE
ONE HUNDRED PEOPLE WITH YOUR
FUNDING KNOW IF WE'RE ABLE TO
INCREASE THE FUNDING WE DON'T TO
START ANOTHER ORGANIZATION WE TO
FUND THE ORGANIZATION SO INSTEAD
OF ONE HUNDRED. WE GET TO TO TWO
HUNDRED TO A THOUSAND.
THAT SHOULD BE WHAT WE NEED TO
DO. BUT I THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
WHAT YOU A PART OF THE
INFORMATION PROVIDED HERE TODAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU MY PLEASURE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT I THINK YOU ARE OUT WE
HAVE EMPOWERING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS AND
STRENGTHENING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES I HAVE OUR TH ANNUAL
LOPEZ EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
MAKES ME CYNICAL IN THEY CANNOT
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONAL
PROJECT.
THANK YOU AND WELCOME.
POEM XIN DATING INTERNATIONALLY
GOT MACHINE THAT GETS YOUR KIND
YOU MEAN THOUGH THAT YOUR NINETY
UP SAY NEARLY ME DIE. YOU AND OF
AYE YOU WE KIND AND TO OWN ME
TOMINAGA NEWMAN DOGMA.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR RUBIO AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NEMESIS
ANNUAL PASS AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR THE MYSTICAL.
IN THE HENNA COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING PROJECT INSHORE IS
MICHAEL OR MICHAEL PERFECT.
.
THERE ARE OVER A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND INDIGENOUS
IMMIGRANT. LIVING WORKING IN
DEVELOPING ROUTES ACROSS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
IN THE CENTER COAST ARE OVER
FORTY NINE THOUSAND
INDIGENOUS IMMIGRANTS.
MICHAEL WAS ESTABLISHED AS
SAPPHIRE WHEN FILE ONE SEAT
THREE. NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION IN
TWO THOUSAND AND ONE. TO SUPPORT
ORGANIZE AND EMPOWER THE
INDIGENOUS IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES.
INVENTOR ACCOUNTING.
OUR REGION IS THE HOME TO
DIFFERENT INDIGENOUS GROUP FROM
THE MEXICAN FROM THE MEXICAN
STATE OF OAXACA AND ATLANTA.
THE MAJORITY OF THE OF OUR
CLIENTS ARMY SPECKLES AND WE
THERAPIST SMALL NUMBERS OF
SUPPLE PICKLES COMMUNITIES.
WELL MY JORDY OF NEEDS MYSTICS
ARE BILINGUAL AND THE SPANISH.
AND MAKES THAT GOAL.
AND NON READING INDIGENOUS A
LAND WHICH MANY ARE MONOLINGUALS
IN THEIR INDIGENOUS LANGUAGE.
AND FACE UP FIND SUBSTANTIAL
LANGUAGE BARRIERS
WHEN ACCESSING TO SERVICES.
MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES WORK IN
LOW PAYING JOB AS FARMWORKERS.
IN VENTURA COUNTY OF OUR CULTURE
INDUSTRY AND ACROSS CUT THAT
CALIFORNIA STATE.
MIKE UP SEEKS TO IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF LIFE OF THE
INDIGENOUS COMMUNITY OF INTERNET
COUNTY.
MY TRAINING COMMUNITY LEADERS
AND COLLECTIVELY IDENTIFY I'VE
COMMUNITY PROBLEMS AND DEVELOP
PROGRAM BASED EFFECTIVE
SOLUTIONS.
THE INDIGENOUS FARMWORKERS
STUDY.
REPORT FROM TWO THOUSAND AND
NINE IDENTIFIES THE MASSIVE
VIOLENCE AS A MAJOR PROBLEM
PROBLEM IN THE INDIGENOUS.
COMMUNITIES STATEWIDE.
DO TO POVERTY LACK OF EDUCATION.
ISOLATION FOR A COMMUNITY
RESOURCESAYS.
AND THE YOUNG H. AT WEEK
MIGRATION. MARRIAGE AND
PREGNANCY O. CORES.
AND TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT.
MIKE UP A STARTED ARE DVD OR THE
MASSIVE VIOLENCE PREVENTION
PROGRAM. IN RESPONSE TO THE HIGH
NUMBERS OF INDIAN AS WOMEN WHO
HAVE APPROACH MY CUP FOR
SUPPORT.
IN LEAVING OR CHANGING THEIR
VIOLENT HOME SITUATIONS.
IN ORDER TO BI CULTURAL WRIST
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE.
TO OUR COMMUNITIES WE CHOOSE TO
NAPA THAT WERE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
AND THAT IN THE NAME OF OUR
PROGRAM.
INSTEAD WE LAUNCH OUR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE LEADERSHIP.
I DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM CALLTHE
BOSS AND I'M GETTING THE HANNAH.
OR BOARD OF INDIGENOUS WOMEN.
WE LATER ADDED THE LIMITS OF
VIOLENCE PREVENTION CURRICULUM.
VIVIAN TOOK ON A MORE LIVING
WOULD LAUGH.
SINCE THEN WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
TO TRANSFORM THE PERCEPTION OF
THE MYTH OF VIOLENCE I'M OWN
VENTURA COUNTY ITS INDIGENOUS
FARMWORKERS COMMUNITY.
TRADITIONALLY MYSTICS HAVE VEAL
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AS A PRIVATE MATTER BETWEEN.
WIFE AND HUSBAND.
AT FIRST OUR TEAM OF TRAINING
DIVISION OF WOMEN'S PROMOTE
THOUGHT SO HEALTHCARE PRO.
OUTREACH WORKERS.
A. THE KIT AT THE WOMEN'S DEMAND
FROM THEIR OWN COMMUNITY ABOUT
THE CYCLE OF VIOLENCE.
LEGAL PROTECTIONS FOR VICTIM.
ABELES
AND THEM IMPACT OF VIOLENCE ON
CHILDREN.
THESE ARE THE CASING IS BEING
PROVIDED IN THE SECOND LANGUAGE.
AND SUPPLE DECAL.
ANDWITH A SPECIAL SENSITIVITY
TO CULTURE BELIEVES.
WE PROVIDE THIS INFORMATION AND
LAUNDROMATS.
FLEA MARKETS.
AND MICHAEL THAT UP WILL.
AND EVEN IN THE STRAWBERRY
FIELDS.
AND TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN
WITH THE GENEROUS SUPPORT OF THE
BLUE SHIELD CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION.
WE HAVE MICHAEL WHERE A WHICH
EXPAND ARE THE ARE THE MISTER
VIOLENCE UMBELS THAT I'M GETTING
THE CAN A PROGRAM.
BUT TRAINING D. V. SURVIVORS.
TO MAKE THE SHIFT FROM A VICTIM.
FROM A VICTIM TO SEE THEMSELVES
AS THE AGENT OF CHANGE.
TWO OLDER WOMEN.
THESE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS BUT
SURVIVORS BECOME THE NEW BOOK
PARABLES PROMOTE THOUGHT THAT'S.
AND THROUGH THEM WE INCREASE OUR
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION. CAPACITY
TO OUR COMMUNITIES AND THE COULD
RELATE AND I DEEPER LEYVA LET
TOM LEVEL TO ALL THE ENVISIONED
AS THE MOST VIOLENT SURVIVORS.
AND TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN.
WINKLER IT ADVOCACY.
AND POLICY CHANGE FOR OUR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS
PUTTING OUR HAVE IMPACT
SYSTEMATIC IMPACT.
I CHANGE.
OUR CURRENT PROGRAM CONCEIVED
THE MULTIPLE COMPONENTS.
THAT INCLUDE LEADERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT.
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION.
ART WORKSHOP.
WILLOW BARKED.
ABOUT DOING THE CAN NOW I
THOUGHT OF ANY STATION WOULD
LAUNCH IRAQ. A RADIO COMMUNITY
COMEDIA RADIO STATION THAT NIGHT
AFFORDABLE POINT ONE LOCALLY YOU
CAN ALSO LISTEN TO OUR RADIO
VIA.
INTERNET.
AND HAVING TO TRAIN OUR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS IN BEACON
MEDIA RADIO DJS.
WE ARE.
.
PROVIDERS NETWORK WHICH
ESTABLISH A NETWORK WITH
KNOWLEDGE AND NETWORK OF THEM IF
THE VIOLENCE SERVICES PROVIDED.
TO BETTER SERVE THE NEED OF
INFUSION OF THE VICTIM OF A
MASSIVE VIOLENCE VENTURA COUNTY.
WE ALSO HOLE ARE I KNOW
CONVENING.
BRING IT TOGETHER TRAIN ME
MISTER A WOMEN'S LEADERS TO
SHARE THEIR EXPANSIVE PROGRAM.
AS I WOULD CONTEND THAT OUR WORK
ON A POWER IN THE MIDST OF
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE MOST
VIOLENT RESOURCES ARE FAR FROM
SUFFICIENT.
WE ALSO RECOGNIZE VAIN TO
INTERSECTION OF THE META
VIOLENCE AND MENTAL HEALTH.
PRELIMINARY DATA FROM ONE OF OUR
RESEARCH AND STUDIES.
SHOWS THAT WE ARE. WHAT WE
ALREADY KNOWS TO BE TRUE?
I DON'T FOUR HUNDRED INDIGENOUS
WOMEN SURVEYED SIXTY HAVE
IDENTIFIED THE METS HAVE
VIOLENCE AYE SOMETHING THAT IS
IMPACTING THEIR MENTAL HEALTH.
TO THE US AND WE ALSO HAVE
WORKED TO IMPROVE THE CULTURAL
RESPONSIVENESS OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES THAT ARE ARE COUNTY.
AND ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
WE CONTRACT WITH OUR.
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT FOR INTERPRETING
SERVICES.
BUT WE ARE ALSO WORKING TO
CHANGE THE TYPE OF SERVICES WE
OFFER OUT THE OFFERING.
WE ARE CURRENTLY WORKING ON TO.
RESEARCH STUDIES.
ONE THAT WILL EVENT A FIVE AND
THE INDIGENOUS PRACTICES TO
MARRIAGE WITH COGNITIVE BEHAVIOR
THERAPY. AND THE OLDER WILL MOVE
A COMMITTED DEVELOP INTERVENTION
DOORS MEAN EVERYTHING BASS.
ARE THESE AT TOM BY THE AT THE
END OF THE OF THESE SOCIETIES WE
WILL HAVE TWO DIFFERENT TOOLS.
TO OVERCOME NATIONS WHO ARE
SERVING OUR INFUSION OF
IMMIGRANT POPULATION IN VENTURA
COUNTY. OR THROUGH THE STATE.
THROUGHOUT HIS WORK.
MIKE UP HAS BEEN BECOME A
TRUSTED RESOURCE.
AND A BROADER BROADER COMMUNITY
AND OTHER DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
PROVIDERS.
WHO REGULARLY TRYING TO ASK FOR
ASSISTANCE SERVING INDIGENOUS LA
COMMUNITIES?
WE PROVIDE TRAININGS BOTH THEM
INTO IRAQ AND SANTA BARBARA MORE
RECENTLY WE'RE EXPANDING.
AND ACROSS THE STATE AS WELL
PATH TO THE IMPORTS OF.
AS WELL ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVENESS.
LANGUAGE ACCESS AND MOVING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIMS FROM
SURVIVORS TO EMPOWER LEADERS.
FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS THINGS SO
MY CUPS LEADERS ADVOCACY LOCALS
OF THE LOCAL DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
PROVIDERS INCLUDING THE POLICE
THE LOCAL POLICE DEPARTMENT. AND
OTHER LEGAL I'M AGENCIES.
STARTED PROVIDING ME SEKELILING
WHICH INTERPRETATIONS WHAT
TARGET THEIR SERVICES SPACE
PATHETICALLY TO THEM THINK
WINDAGE ENOUGH COMMUNITIES.
MAKEUP ALSO HAVE BEGUN BUILDING
A RELATIONSHIP WITH ALL AREA
SERVICE PROVIDER PROVIDERS BY
COMBINING OUR OWN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE NETWORK. IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE A MORE HOLISTIC SERVICES
FOR OUR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS.
BUT AT THE HIGH NUMBER OF
INDIGENOUS WOMEN'S REPORT
VIOLENCE AND SICK ASSISTANT.
THE ISN'T NETWORK NEEDS GREATER
UNITY AND IMPROVE CULTURALLY.
COMPETENCY AND LINGUISTIC ACCESS
TO ME THAT'S NEAT.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE SUCCESS OF
MAKEUP OUT SEVENTEEN YEARS OF
WORK AND INDIGENOUS COMMITTEES
COMMUNITY. AND OUR IT'S OUR USE
OF THAT.
IT'S BECAUSE WE HAVE A BY
PROMONTORIES ARMADO.
MY TRAINING MISTER COMMUNITY
LEADERS TO BE THERE SERVICE
PROVIDERS.
WE ARE ABLE TO BUILD TRUST AND
CONFIDENCE IN WAYS THAT OTHER
PROVIDERS ARE UNABLE TO.
WHEN SURE THAT OUR PROGRAMS I
HAVEN'T WITH LINGUISTICALLY ACT
ACCESSIBLE AND DIRECTLY MEET
COMMUNITY NEEDS.
I THOUGHT ANYTHING XIN MIKE UP
WITH KNOWLEDGE OF THE WRECK
SERVICES.
BUT AN OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR
INFUSION OF LIMITED DEVELOP.
THEIR LEADERSHIP AND THEIR VOICE
TO BE THE CHANGE MAKERS.
OUR INVASION OF THE OF THE
SURVIVORS ARE AMAZING AND THEY
CAN MAKE A CHANGE NOT ONLY.
FOR THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES
BUT TWO OLDER WOMEN'S AS WELL.
BY THIS CHANGE CAN ONLY BE
ACHIEVED VIA COLLABORATION.
IT IS GOING TO TAKE THEM.
AS LEADER.
PASS.
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION.
AND YOU A CALIFORNIA ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES.
TOGETHER WE CAN AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND OUR STATE.
WINDOWS FOR THEM WAS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'LL BRING
IT UP TO THE COMMITTEE FIVE DO
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SCRIPTED THANK YOU DO YOU HAVE
ANY.
PROGRAM SERVICES THAT ALSO
FOCUS ON MAN WHO WAS WHO HAVE
BEEN VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE BECAUSE.
LOOKING AT NUMBERS IN THESE
NUMBERS ARE. SEEM TO INCREASE IN
TERMS OF MEN. WHO?
ARE VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND WE SHOULD YOU KNOW
THIS CROSSES THIS ISN'T OF MEN
AND WOMEN WHO'VE BEEN VICTIMIZED
IN THIS PARTICULAR SPACE.
MONADO MEN.
IS ARE VERY APPREHENSIVE IN
TERMS OF REPORTING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE BECAUSE YOU WERE RAISED
TO BE MACHO AND STRONG. IT CAN
NEVER HAPPEN TO ME AS A MAN BUT
IN FACT IT DOES.
WHERE THE YOU ARE GAY MAN OR
STRAIGHT MAN IT HAPPENS THAT I'M
LOOKING AT NUMBERS THAT YOU KNOW
BEING?
GAY MAN IT HAPPENS QUITE OFTEN
IN RELATIONSHIPS RIGHT SO ARE
THERE ANY SERVICES.
THAT YOU PROVIDE FOR MEN WHO
ARE WHO ARE VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE YOU CAN SPEAK TO.
PROBABLY THREE YEARS AGO WE
STARTED EIGHT MEN PROGRAMS THAT
WHAT'S CALL ON. AND THEIR OWN
BUDGETS AMONG MEN.
AND I WASN'T ACTUALLY WITH A ONE
YEAR PROGRAM.
AND TO BE HONEST JUST TO GAIN
THE TRUSTS
FROM OUR COMMUNITIES AND
PARTICULARLY MAN AND IS WELL
KNOWN DEMANDS ARE WE HAVING
CHALLENGESOR PROVIDE SERVICE
PROVIDERS INCLUDING HEALTH.
CARE AGENCIES ARE HAVING A LOT
OF CHALLENGES TO GET MEN.
TO HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTH. AND GO
THAT BASIC TESTS WAS VERY KIND
OF SIMILAR.
TO WHAT OUR EXPERIENCE WANTS.
SO WOULD YOU AGREE THAT A GROUP
OF OUR TEN MEN.
AND WE TRAIN THEM AS
SPECIFICALLY AROUND OUR
LEADERSHIP.
DEVELOPMENT TRAINING.
BUT ALSO WERE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
BY LINDS ON. IN THE FAMILY.
AND ALSO HEALTHY COMMUNICATION
WITH OUR AND AND RELATIONSHIP.
AND THAT'S THAT WE WERE BUILDING
THAT PROGRAM UNFORTUNATELY A LOT
OF THAT WORK DEPENDS ON
FINDINGS.
SO.
.
THAT WHAT'S THAT AS THE BEAK I I
WITH A BIG CHALLENGE TO KEEP
THAT PROGRAM GOING.
SO WE TRIED OUR BEST TO KEEP THE
PROGRAM BUT BECAUSE I FIND THAT
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO KEEP THAT PART
TIME.
AND COORDINATOR AT OUR
ORGANIZATION AT THAT TIME.
HOWEVER THE RECENT.
THROUGH THE IT'S ON CURRICULUM
THAT GIVE WE DEVELOP THEIR
SCHOOL LEAVING WE LOFT OR EVEN
THE ONE I'M MORE.
THERE'S TWO PART OF IT THERE IS
TO WIND THAT WE ARE DOING THIS
RESEARCH STUDY TOOK FOR THAT
CURRICULUM THROUGH A GRANT. FROM
THE STATE.
BUT ALSO WE HAVE AYE AYE
CONTRACT WITH A LOCAL BEEKEEPER
HEALTH ON.
DEPARTAMENTO HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
AND IT'S A SMALL BUT BROWN IS A
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS GRAND
FOR ONE YEAR.
AND WE ONLY HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
HAVE ONE PERSON THE TEN HOURS
PER WEEK.
TO PROVIDE THAT ONLY CLASS IN
THAT CLASS IT'S WE STARTED THE
CLASS WITHOUT A WOMEN ONLY
CLASS.
BUT BECAUSE OF THE WOMEN'S
HISTORY HAVING THAT DEMANDS OF.
THEM BEING MORE INTERESTED TO
BRING THEIR PARTNERS WITH THEM.
SO WE STARTED OPEN THAT.
PROGRAM TO BE.
.
WIFE AND HUSBAND.
I CLASSES TO GET FOR THAT ONLY.
.
CLASSES LEAVING WOULD LOVE.
I THINK SOMEONE MENTIONED IT
EARLIER.
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF.
.
KIND OF CULTURAL BELIEFS
THAT WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND FROM
THE NOT ONLY THE LATINO BY THE
INDIGENOUS COMMUNITIES. AND
THAT'S A LOT OF OTHER FACTORS
THAT INFLUENCE ON THE DECISION
THE PEOPLE BY CALLING THE POLICE
HAVE THERE'S A VIOLENCE.
SO DO THE LESS THAT OUR PEOPLE
WERE MAINLY WOMEN ARE VICTIMS
THAT THEY WANT TO DO IS TO CALL
THE POLICE BECAUSE HE THE CALL
THAT BELIEF IN THE PUT UP POLICE
ON THERE HAS BEEN. THEY KNOW
THAT THAT PERSON WILL BE
DEPORTED.
AND THAT WILL BE A FAMILY
SEPARATION.
SO THERE IS SOME WOMEN'S THAT
THEY DON'T WANT TO COME A PHONE
AND SAY I'M HAVING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE THAT'S THAT INSTEAD OF
HAVING MORE LIKE WHAT IS.
WHAT KIND OF RESOURCES IS THERE
SO I CAN INCLUDE MY HOUSE WHEN
IN THE CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW
CAN WE IMPROVE OUR RELATIONSHIP?
AND I THINK SOME OF THEM THE
STARTED SEEING LEVON WOULD LAUGH
CLASS THIS AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO
THAT. OF IN THIS SPACE.
FOR THAT.
THINK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
WELL THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH AND I AT THIS POINT I
WANT TO OPEN IT UP TO THE PUBLIC
IF YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR.
ANYTHING THAT YOU WISH TO ADD
TO THIS CONVERSATION WERE
LOOKING FORWARD TO A GAME THIS
BEING THE FIRST OF MANY.
WE HEARINGS THAT WE CAN
HOPEFULLY.
HAVE SOME OUTCOMES TO
ALRIGHT.
ERICA GOOD AFTERNOON.
IF YOU SO MUCH FOR.
THE.
TODAY INTO
I ABOUT OF WHAT I KNOW IS.
BUSY BUSY WEEK CARE HOSPITAL. BY
ON BEHALF OF THE APPROPRIATE
PART.
THE STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION THAT.
DISTINCT PLEASURE BUDGET WORKING
WHEN. EVERYONE THAT YOU'VE HEARD
TODAY AND OUR COLLEAGUE CALLED.
STATE.
NO I.
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
ISRAEL IN ONE I THINK YOU ALL
FOR MAKING THE TIME.
CHEN. FORWARD TO WORKING WITH.
THROUGHOUT THE.
THANK YOU.
OKAY
.
HI. WHO Z. AND I'M?
TING EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT ASIAN
WOMEN SHELTER IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND I JUST WANTED TO.
SHARE A COUPLE OF MOMENTS WITH
YOU FROM MY WORK AT A W. S. I'VE
BEEN THERE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND ONE.
AND.
I THINK THAT ONE OF THE THINGS
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO IT ASIAN
WOMAN SHELTER AS A CULTURALLY
GROUNDED SHELTER PROGRAM. THAT
DOES
FULL. CASE MANAGEMENT FULL
SUPPORT THAT'S IN A RESIDENTIAL
EMERGENCY CITING AS WELL AS IN
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING CITING AS
WELL AS JUST COMMUNITY BASED NON
RESIDENTIAL SERVICES. WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO REALLY INTEGRATE.
PREVENTION AND INTERVENTION
SERVICES TOGETHER IN OVER FORTY
TWO LANGUAGES SINCE WE OPENED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
AND THE THING THAT I ONE THING
THAT I WANNA RESPECTFULLY DO
WITH THE WITH THE COMMITTEE IS.
IS SHARE A PERSPECTIVE.
HOME FROM ME THAT REALLY STARTS
WITH MY FAMILY EXPERIENCE I
DON'T ACTUALLY TALK ABOUT MY
FAMILY VERY MUCH BUT CONNIE
INSPIRED ME.
SO I'M A SO MY MY GRANDMOTHER.
MY GRANDMOTHER WAS.
IN HONJO IN CHINA SHE WAS BORN
AND RAISED THERE AND I LEARNED
LATER AFTER SHE HAD COME TO
BERKELEY AS A SENIOR CITIZEN.
THAT IN HER YOUNGER YEARS SHE
WAS THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SHELTER OF HER TOWN.
AND SHE WOULD BRING IN WOMEN
KNEW THAT THAT WAS THE HOUSE
THAT THEY COULD GO TO. AND THAT
MY LITTLE FOUR FOOT ELEVEN
GRANDMOTHER WHO WAS REALLY QUITE
DOMINEERING AND POWERFUL.
IN BOTH GREAT WAYS AND
OCCASIONALLY CHALLENGING ONES
WAS JUST AS STRONG AND BOLD.
THEN AS SHE WAS LATER IN HER
EIGHTIES AND NINETIES AND SHE
WOULD WELCOME WOMEN INTO HER
HOUSE.
AND SHE WOULD SUPPORT THEM AND
ONE OF HER TAGLINES WAS YOU
KNOW.
YOU'RE GONNA BE OKAY THE WORLD
SAYS HUSBANDS ARE EVERYTHING BUT
FRIENDS ARE BETTER.
AND THEY COULD STAY AT HER HOUSE
AND STAY WITH HER UNTIL.
USUALLY THEY FELT LIKE THEY
COULD GO BACK.
TO A SLIGHTLY DE ESCALATED
SITUATION.
LATER MY MOM THOUGHT SHE WOULD
HAVE A BETTER SITUATION BECAUSE
EVEN MY GRANDMOTHER WAS A
SURVIVOR OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
FROM MY GRANDFATHER EVEN WITH
ALL OF THAT.
POWER THAT SHE HAD.
AND.
AND I WANNA SHARE THAT IN MY
EXPERIENCE WITHIN MY FAMILY AND
AND SOME OF OUR WORK AT ASIAN
WOMEN'S SHELTER. THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO SEE THAT HURT
PEOPLE HURT PEOPLE. AND.
HURT PEOPLE DON'T HURT PEOPLE.
AND.
AND THE IN MY FAMILY AND IN MANY
OF THE FAMILIES AT A W. S. THAT
HAVE COME TO A W. ASK WHAT WE
SEE IS DEEP DEEP ROOTS OF
PATRIARCHAL ENTITLEMENT.
AND ARE CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE
PROGRAMS ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
BEST SITUATED TO DISMANTLE THAT
PATRIARCHAL ENTITLEMENT. AND
THAT PATRIARCHAL ENTITLEMENT IT
MIGHT NOT BE ENTITLEMENT OVER
YOUR WORKPLACE IT MIGHT NOT BE
ENTITLEMENT OVER YOUR ENTIRE
LIFE HERE IN THE U. S. AS A
MARGINALIZED PERSON. OR
MARGINALIZED MAN BUT IT IS
PATRIARCHAL ENTITLEMENT
SPECIFICALLY OVER YOUR FEMALE
PARTNER AND YOUR CHILDREN. AND
THOUGHT WE'D BECAUSE WE'RE WITH
FAMILIES ALL THE TIME THROUGH
THE CHILDREN'S PROGRAM WE HAVE
TRANSFORMED.
SIBLING UNITS.
WHERE A SON HAS BEEN TOLD SINCE
BIRTH THAT HE IS PURE PERFECTION
JUST FOR EXISTING?
EVERY MOVE THAT HE MAKES.
IS TREASURED.
AND HIS SISTER MIGHT GET A
COMPLIMENT IF SHE HELPS HIM HARD
ENOUGH.
AND OTHERWISE SHE'S JUST.
THAT NOTHING.
AND WE THAT THAT THOSE ARE SOME
OF THE ROOTS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE THAT HAPPENED ALL BY
THEMSELVES WITHIN THE FAMILY
SETTING AND IN THE LARGER
CULTURAL SETTING WHERE MAYBE
BOTH OF THOSE PEOPLE ARE
SUFFERING THE EFFECTS. OF
SYSTEMIC RACISM THEY BOTH
SUFFERING THE EFFECTS OF
IMMIGRATION OF NOT BEING ABLE
LATER TO COMMUNICATE WITH THEIR
PARENTS IN THE SAME LANGUAGE LA
LA LA.
THAT ENTITLEMENT STARTS YOUNG
AND WHEN WE CAN BE CULTURALLY
RESPONSIVE ORGANIZATIONS FUNDED
TO DO PREVENTION WORK AS PART OF
OUR INTERVENTION WORK THEY ARE
INTERCONNECTED. WE CAN ACTUALLY
CHANGE AND HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
CHANGE. THOSE DYNAMICS AS THEIR
LIVED IN THE DATED A WITHIN A
FAMILY AND WE KNOW THAT JUST AS
WITH UNHEALTHY. IS
INTERGENERATIONAL AND COMPOUNDS
OVER TIME WHAT'S HEALTHY DOES
TO.
AND WHEN YOU CHANGE THAT IN THE
SHELTER YOU CHANGE THE AND A
FAMILY EARN A CONGREGATION
THAT'S GOING TO GO GENERATION
AFTER GENERATION AND NOTS WHAT I
REALLY WANT TO IMPRESS UPON YOU
IS PART OF THIS. ASK
FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO SUPPORT
THE ENDING OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
IN WAYS THAT HAVE THE BIGGEST
IMPACT IN THE QUICKEST WAY.
THANKS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO.
MY NAME IS RACHEL I AM CHARCOAL
APACHE IN THE HAN AUTUMN. AND
MEXICAN ON MY FATHER'S SIDE.
AND MY ASK IS THAT I LOVE THE
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING HERE AND I
ABSOLUTELY LOVE THE CONVERSATION
THAT WE'RE HAVING. I WORK AS AN
ADVOCATE IN THE COMMUNITY. AND
WHAT I HAVE NOT HEARD AND WHAT
I'M FINDING IS THAT ARE
INDIGENOUS WOMEN IN OUR NATIVE
AMERICAN POPULATION IS NOT ON
YOUR MAP.
AND.
ICE IT HAD RECEIVED A MESSAGE
THIS MORNING FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE THE MISSING IN
CALIFORNIA. DEPARTMENT THE WOMAN
WHO WORKS IN NOT.
DEPARTMENT OR PROGRAM BY
REQUESTED A NUMBER FOR THE
MISSING NATIVE WOMEN IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN THE LAST
TEN YEARS. AND SHE LET ME KNOW
THAT THEY DID THERE IS NOT A
CODE.
FOR US.
.
I GREW UP AS A MEXICAN AMERICAN
BECAUSE IT WAS NOT SAFE FOR US
TO BE INDIAN.
AND SO WE ARE IN THIS URBAN
COMMUNITY WHERE A LOT OF NATIVES
ARE AND A LOT OF US HIDE UNDER.
OUR OTHER MIXED RACE WHICH WOULD
BE NATIVE OR AFRICAN AMERICAN IT
EASIER FOR US TO COME OUT THAT
WAY.
AS FAR AS MY FRIENDS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ARE CONSERVED
TRYING TO DO AND MAKE.
BE VISIBLE FOR MISSING AND
MURDERED INDIGENOUS WOMEN WERE
GETTING A LOT OF.
.
ROAD BLOCKS IN BARRIERS BECAUSE
THE NUMBERS ARE NOT REPORTED
BECAUSE WE'RE STILL VERY MUCH AN
INDIGENT.
INVISIBLE POPULATION. I
RECENTLY HAD A CONVERSATION WITH
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
THAT WORKS WITH THE SEX
TRAFFICKING UNIT THEY ALSO.
AREN'T AWARE OF THE URBAN
POPULAR BEEN INDIAN POPULATION
HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
IS KIND OF FUNNY BECAUSE HE
SAYS WE DON'T THINK YOU KNOW WE
THINK INDIANS LOOK LIKE THEY DO
ON THE RESERVATION AND HE WAS
ABLE TO NAME SOME OF THE
RESERVATIONS THAT WERE OUTSIDE.
BUT IT WAS A VERY.
.
I OPENING FOR HIM AND FOR THEM
TO NOT NOTICE THAT.
I LOOK I EIGHT JUST LIKE AN
INDIAN YOU KNOW AND SO.
.
WHAT I'D LIKE TO SEE AND WHO I
IS I I NEED A CONTACT OF HOW IT
IS THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO FIND PEOPLE LIKE ME? WHO
IDENTIFY SOMETIMES IS MEXICAN
BECAUSE SOMETIMES IT'S EASIER
SOMETIMES IT'S SAFER FOR US?
AND SO.
WITH THAT I FEEL LIKE THAT
CONVERSATION CAN BE PRETTY
EFFECTIVE AND CULTURALLY ARM WE
DON'T.
WE ARE FAITH WE ARE NOT FAITH
BASED IN THE TRADITIONAL SENSE
AND SO THE WAY THAT WE ARE ABLE
TO HEAL. IS THROUGH ARE
CEREMONIES AND A LOT OF THOSE
CEREMONIES ARE COMMUNICATED
BECAUSE IT'S JUST NOT SAFE TO DO
SO.
.
MY ASK WOULD BE. WHO I ASK?
OKAY.
OKAY THANK YOU.
SOAK CRYSTALS TAKING NOTES AND
AND THAT IS THE PURPOSE OF THIS
HOT THE BEGINNING OF THIS THIS
HEARING IS TO. TO IDENTIFY THE.
OBVIOUSLY THE ISSUES OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE BUT WHAT.
GROUPS ARE NOT BEING REPRESENTED
AND BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW THAT.
THERE'S SO MANY OF CULTURES
THAT ARE NOT BEING REPRESENTED
OUR RURAL COMMUNITIES ARE NOT
BEING.
REPRESENTED EITHER OF THEIR IS
VERY DIFFERENT NEEDS IN THE
RURAL COMMUNITIES THAT ARE ON
THE URBAN COMMUNITY SO THANK YOU
FOR ASKING AND CRYSTAL IF YOU
LEAVE YOUR INFORMATION WE CAN
GET.
SHE CAN GIVE YOU YOUR HER
INFORMATION WE CAN WORK WITH YOU
ON ON I'LL HOPE.
HOPEFULLY IDENTIFYING AND I
ADDING BAD.
BACK TO AYE DESIGNATION TO TO
THE TRACKING SYSTEM SO THANK YOU
AGAIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON ARE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH
ARM FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS
ISSUE MY NAME IS JOHN LANCASTER
FINLEY A REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION AGAINST
SEXUAL ASSAULT. AND I'M HERE TO
STAND ARM WITH SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE BUT ALSO JUST
TO BRING TO THE COMMITTEE'S
ATTENTION ON THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN THE ISSUES OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL ASSAULT. I
THINK.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE HOW THE
STATE HAS BUILT A STRONG
INFRASTRUCTURE IN STRONG SAFETY
NET FOR INTERVENING IN IMMEDIATE
MOMENTS OF CRISIS BUT WE ALSO
WANT TO.
ACKNOWLEDGE AND REAFFIRM THE
FOLKS WHO HAVE WHO HAVE SPOKEN
OUT ABOUT HOW OUR CURRENT
SYSTEMS ARE NOT SEEN OR NOT
REACHING EVERYBODY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ON ONE
A SURVIVOR STEPS INTO INTO A
RAPE CRISIS CENTER WENT TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SHELTER
THEY'RE CARRYING WITH THE MANY
DIFFERENT FORMS OF PAIN IN MANY
DIFFERENT FORMS OF VIOLENCE. ON
OUR STATE NEEDS TO BE RESPONSIVE
TO THE FACT THAT SURVIVORS ARE
EXPERIENCING MANY DIFFERENT
FORMS I ALSO WANT TO SPEAK TO
THE IMPORTANCE OF PREVENTION AND
SAY THAT FIRST AND FOREMOST OF
PREVENTION EDUCATION. SPEAKS TO
THE NECESSITY THAT MAN BE
EQUIPPED WITH THE CAPACITY TO
KNOW BETTER TO DO BETTER AND TO
BE BETTER AND THAT'S HOW WE'LL
START WORKING TOWARD SOLVING.
THESE PROBLEMS TOWARD SOLVING
THESE MULTIPLE FORMS OF VIOLENCE
THAT INFLICTED ON PEOPLE ON THAT
THE STATE NEEDS TO COMMIT
RESOURCES NEEDS TO COMMIT
ATTENTION I NEED TO GET THOSE
RESOURCES TO POCKETS OF THAT'S
PART OF OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT THEY'RE NOT
CURRENTLY REACHING AND SO WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES
DEDICATION TO THIS AND WE
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
ON ESPECIALLY FOR CHAMPING A
BUDGET REQUEST THAT WE GET THOSE
TYPES OF RESOURCES TO PLACES
WHERE THEY'RE NOT CURRENTLY
GOING. BUT ALSO TO START
ADDRESSING THESE FORMS OF
VIOLENCE IS CONNECTED AND THAT
IMPACT PEOPLE IN MULTIPLE WAYS
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE.
MELA MY NAME IS AYE WINDISCH
LATER FROM THE LOVELY AMANDA
LISTING OF INDIANS DOWN IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M HERE WITH THIS YEAR
DEVIANT ON NETWORK AS WELL.
TODAY AND I'M.
HOW TO DO THE WORK WITH MY
SISTERS AND? I JUST WANT TO ECHO
THE IMPORTANCE OF.
.
BRINGING RESOURCES TO
CULTURALLY.
RESPONSE A PROGRAMMING THAT
HAVE.
THE VALUE SYSTEM. IN THE
COMMUNITY
TO BE ABLE TO CREATE THE
PROGRAMMING THAT DIDN'T THAT.
AND THE RESOURCES THAT NEED TO
BE DONE TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS
IN OUR IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
.
TWO SO. WE'VE WE BASICALLY GET
OUR FUNDING FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
THROUGH OVW.
AND ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO.
THE.
PUNE THEY SWITCHED OUR POLICY.
OF WHERE WE COULD START TO
CREATE REALLY MEN'S REEDUCATION
PROGRAMS.
AND.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN RUBIO YEAR
FEELINGS ARE.
LEGITIMIZE JUSTIFY PAYING AND.
YOU KNOW BECAUSE I WAS LIKE WHY.
PRIMITIVES NAM WE NEED MORE WE
NEED MORE RESOURCES IN SOME.
BUT.
THERE WAS AN ADVOCACY OF SHIFT.
OF THAT OUR MEN ARE NOT
THROWAWAYS.
THAT THEY ARE PART OF MY
COMMUNITY THERE ARE FATHERS
THERE ARE SIGNS OUR NEPHEWS OUR
GRANDSONS.
AND.
.
ON ARE PILLARS IN OUR INNER
SUPPOSED TO HAVE A ROLE OF BEING
PROTECTORS.
AND.
IF WE CONTINUE TO THROW THEM
AWAY.
THEN HOW ARE WE EVER GOING TO
REALLY BREAK THE CYCLE.
AND SO WE STARTED TO REALLY
THINK ABOUT THAT AND.
AND BECAUSE WE GOT THE
FLEXIBILITY IN OUR PROGRAMMING.
WE START TO DEVELOP CULTURAL
SPECIFIC PROGRAMMING FUHRMAN.
YOU KNOW WHETHER IT BE WITH THE
RATTLES.
AND BECAUSE THE COURT THE COURT
BATTLES ARE.
OUR SACRED STUFF YOU'RE TOUCHING
A SACRED OBJECT WITH YOUR HAND.
THEN YOUR HAND ISN'T SUPPOSED TO
BE HURTING ANYBODY ELSE.
ARE YOURSELF.
AND SO I'M. SO THERE'S A LOT TO
BE SAID ABOUT.
PUTTING MORE RESOURCES INTO
CULTURAL SPECIFIC PROGRAMS
WHETHER THEY'RE IN. INDIAN
COUNTRY.
THE KOREAN COMMUNITY LATIN NEXT
COMMUNITY.
THE DEATH OF.
.
THE DEAF COMMUNITY.
AND BECAUSE.
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
THE MOST.
LAKE ARM ON THE GROUND KNOWLEDGE
AND BAIT AND BEING ABLE TO.
TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES AND SO I
WELCOME YOU TO COME AND AND DO A
LISTENING SESSION.
MAYBE THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M IN DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES.
AND WE SERVICE WE HAVE ACCESS TO
THE RIVERSIDE SAN BERNARDINO.
SAN DIEGO TRIBES THAT ARE IN
WORLD COMMUNITY.
AND WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO HOST
THAT.
AND.
AND THEN MAYBE WE COULD WORK
BUT THE C. R. D. VAN.
IN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA IN IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA TEN TO WORK
WITH YOU FOR THOSE LISTENING
SESSIONS.
SO THAT WE COULD JUSTIFY TO YOUR
COLLEAGUES ON WHY YOU NEED.
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS GO TOWARDS
PREVENTION.
AND I'M JUST GETTING ALL OF IT
BUT.
BUT WHY MONIES TOWARDS THEM.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
HI MY NAME WITH HAVE AT THE
THOMAS I WORK FOR WE'VE WHICH IS
JUST DOWN THE STREET HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. AS THE DIRECTOR OF
RESPONSE ORBISON'S.
I WANT TO SPEAK ABOUT THE NEED
FOR PREVENTION.
AND RECOGNIZED THAT I FEEL THAT
OFTENTIMES THE TERM PREVENTION
IS SEEN AS JUST.
ONE THING. IT IS PREVENTING WHAT
HAS NOT HAPPENED AND OBVIOUSLY
THIS IS HAPPENING. SO REALLY
CREATING A FULL FRAME. KIND OF.
SURE AND IDEA AND CONCEPT AROUND
PREVENTION AND RECOGNIZING THAT
THERE'S A HUGE COMPONENT OF
HEALING AS WE HEARD FROM MANY OF
THE SPEAKERS TODAY. IN
RECOGNIZING THAT THAT WILL ALSO
HELP PREVENTION OF CONTINUED
CYCLES OF VIOLENCE
WITHIN FAMILIES.
AND.
ALSO WANT TO SPEAK TO.
HOW INCREDIBLE?
THE FOCUS ON BEING CULTURALLY
RESPONSIVE ILLS.
AND I DO INVITE YOU TO COME TO
LEAVE AT ANYTIME MEET WITH BATH
OR C. E. O..
OR ANY OF US AND WE HAVE A LOT
OF EMBEDDED PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL THAT ARE MOSTLY
FUNDED BY PRIVATE FOUNDATIONS.
INCLUDING HAVING INVENTED
ADVOCATES.
AT SNACK.
OUT.
WITH A FAMILY HEALTH CENTER AND
WE ALSO PARTNER WITH OTHER.
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE ARM.
CULTURALLY FOCUSED.
AGENCIES WITH IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY SO RECOGNIZING THAT WE
ARE ONE OF THE MAINSTREAM
AGENCIES BUT WE ABSOLUTELY
ACCESS AND RESOURCE. WHAT ELSE
EXISTS
HANDS GOING BACK TO NOT
REINVENTING THE WHEEL? I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT SO THANK YOU
FOR.
TAKING OVER OUR WORDS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE.
OKAY WELL ENCLOSING AYE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON WHICH LIKE
TO THINK. THROUGH OUR FIRST VOTE
ONCE I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AGAIN.
CHAIRWOMAN RUBIO FOR ONE.
HAVING THE VISION.
TO BRING US ALL TOGETHER TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION UP INTO
SPACE AND CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
IMMENSELY THOSE WHO HAVE ALREADY
THOSE WHO'VE TESTIFIED. OF THOSE
THEMSELVES WHO'S BEEN VICTIMS
ITS BUT SURVIVORS
OF DOMESTIC BUYS WE REALLY
APPRECIATE DOT ONE YOU BEING
HERE IN STANDING UP FOR THOSE.
WHO CAN'T STAND UP FOR
THEMSELVES
I WANT TO COMMEND YOU ON WINE?
MAKING AN EFFORT TO BE HERE. OF
THAT LETTING YOUR PRESENCE AND
YOUR VOICES BE MADE KNOWN AND
HEARD AND FELT.
AND VIBRATE THROUGH NOW IN THIS
ROLE BUT ALSO ECHO THROUGHOUT
THIS CHAMBER I THINK IS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT.
A CONVERSATION FOR US HAVING
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I. WANT
TO JUST DRAWS SUGGESTION IS THAT
MAYBE INVITING EVERY PROVIDER
INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA TO HAVE TO
SUE BECAUSE WE WANT TO THINGS I
WANT TO SEE IT. WHO'S DOING WHAT
MAYBE WE ARE DUPLICATING THESE
EFFORTS.
AND WE NEED TO BE FOCUSED ON
HOTTER SPREAD OUT BECAUSE I'M
SURE THERE'S AREAS WITH IN
CALIFORNIA THERE ARE DEFICITS.
OR IN ME ANEMIC THAT YOU KNOW
SERVICES ARE NOT BEING PROVIDED
AND THERE'S PEOPLE YEARNING AND
CRYING OUT BUT WE CAN NEVER HEAR
THEIR VOICES BECAUSE THERE'S NO
ONE CLOSE BY TO HEAR. AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE ARE
NO AREAS.
THAT ARE LEFT UNCOVERS ALMOST
LIKE THAT LEAVE NO MAN LEAVE
GNOME WOMAN BEHIND. ON A WE NEED
TO DO A BETTER JOB IN TERMS OF
OUR RESOURCES BUT ALSO
COLLABORATING TOGETHER TO TRY TO
ADDRESS HOW DO WE.
ERADICATE.
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE MOVING
FOURTEEN SO SONY MY COMMITMENT.
IS HERE.
UNDER YOUR LEADERSHIP AND AND
AND CERTAINLY WANT TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO TRY TO GET
THE RESOURCES INTO THESE
ORGANIZATIONS HANDS WHO'S REALLY
ON THE FRONTLINE. OF OF OF ALL
OF THIS SO I COMMEND EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU AND THANK.
HELP ME THINK ARE CHAIR PLEASE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WELL IN.
CLOSING I WOULD LIKE TO THINK.
ARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS BY.
IE ALREADY EXPRESS TO YOU MY
FIRST AHA. MOMENT AND I WANT TO
THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON FOR
FOR.
OPENING MY EYES UP TO THAT IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT I YOU KNOW.
THINKING ABOUT WHAT YOU SAID AND
AND LISTENING TO WHAT YOU SAID
ABOUT OUR MEN NOT BEING
THROWAWAYS. ALTHOUGH I WOULD
LIKE TO THROW AWAY SOME OF
THOSE.
MARTIN THAT WE UNDERSTAND THAT
PREVENTION MEANS PREVENTING.
MEN AND WOMEN FROM ACTUALLY
DOING.
THE THE ABUSING ARE BEING THE
ABUSERS AND YOU KNOW WE THINK
ABOUT AYE ABOUT PREVENTION AS IN
A PREVENTING THE ACT TOO HAPPY
FROM HAPPENING. BUT I ONLY
VIEWED AS.
VICTIM CENTERED PREVENTION AND
IT'S GOING TO TAKE ME WHILE I
HAVE TO BE VERY HONEST WITH YOU
TO THINK ABOUT.
PREVENTION BEING. AYE EDUCATING
THOSE THEY ABUSERS.
AND FOR THEM TO NOT COMMIT THESE
ACTS AND I WANNA THANK YOU FOR
THAT.
IT'S HARD I MEAN I'M BEING VERY
HONEST WITH YOU BECAUSE NOW I
HAVE TO CHANGE MY FRAME OF MIND
AND NOT BE ANGRY. AT
I MY SISTER'S ABUSER FOR WHAT HE
DID BUT MORE NOW TRYING TO
PREVENT HIM FROM DOING IT AGAIN
TO SOMEBODY ELSE BUT IN GENERAL
PREVENTING MAN. I IN WOMEN FROM
COMMITTING THESE ACTS AND I.
.
ONE THAT THIS TO BE DIFFERENT
RIGHT BECAUSE IN MY MIND I'M
GOING TO DO THIS AND DAM THEM
YOU KNOW EXAGGERATE SETUP BUT
IT'S NOT THAT WAY. I ALSO HAVE
TO TURN ON MY EMPATHY.
METER FOR THE ABUSERS BECAUSE.
THEY ARE HURTING AS WELL THE
REASON THAT THEY'RE DOING THIS
IS BECAUSE THERE'S SOME HEART
AND THEIR LIFE AS WELL. AND SO
IT'S GONNA TAKE ME AWHILE BUT
BUT THIS IS ALL THE PROCESS.
FOR HEALING I'M QUITE FRANKLY
NO I WASN'T THE VICTIM BUT.
THROUGH MY SISTER I AM THE
VICTIM.
AND THE HEALING PROCESS HAS TO
TO TAKE CALLED.
AND ARE THE COMMENTS ABOUT
BEING MORE REGIONAL I THINK IS
WHY WHY WE MET IN THE FIRST
PLACE I ATE MY HOPE MY VISION IS
TO. TAKE THESE CONVERSATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I'VE
ALREADY ASKED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GETS AND IF WE CAN DO WHEN IN
THE COURSE AND.
SO WE'RE WORKING ON THAT FIGHT
BUT IT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
IT'S VERY DIFFERENT AYE LOOKS
VERY DIFFERENT IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THAT THE IT DOESN'T
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND THEN RURAL
CALIFORNIA AND URBAN CALIFORNIA
SO I NEED YOU. TO HELP ME
IDENTIFY THE REGIONS THAT WOULD
WELCOME SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
WERE WILLING TO TAKE IT ON THE
ROAD.
AYE THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS IS.
COMMITTED TO.
PROVIDING THE FUNDING TO
SUPPORT US TAKING.
OUR CONVERSATIONS UP AND DOWN
THE STATE.
BUT.
TO EVERYONE HERE AND EVERYBODY
WATCHING PLEASE ENGAGE
MY OFFICE AND THE ARE MY
COLLEAGUES OFFICES INTO WHAT YOU
THINK.
CAN BE DONE AND MY* MY
OTHER ASK FOR TODAY'S TO YOU
KNOW THE PARTNERSHIP TO HELP US
IDENTIFY THOSE ORGANIZATIONS AND
THOSE GROUPS THAT ARE ALREADY.
HAVE PROGRAMS THAT ARE WORKING
SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO
REINVENT THE WHEEL AND IN HOPES
OF TAKING SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS.
YOU KNOW FROM KOREA TOWN TO
OTHER COMMUNITIES UP AND DOWN
THE STATE BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT I THINK WE'RE AT THE
POINT WHERE. YOU KNOW THE
CONVERSATIONS ARE HAPPENING BY
WE NEED ACTION AS WELL AND IF WE
CAN. HAVE A CONVERSATION AND
HAVE SOME ACTION AFTER I THINK
THAT IS WHAT THE HOPE IN THE
VISION IS.
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE THE
THE.
IBM'S MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE FOR
TAKING YOUR TIME TO BE HERE AND
EDUCATE US ON ON WHAT THIS IS A
WHAT WE NEED TO DO AND THE
PANELISTS THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH.
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IT AGAIN IT
OPENED MY EYES TO WHAT IS
ALREADY AVAILABLE AND HOW MUCH
WORK WE DO HAVE TO DO I WANTED
TO THANK ON DOCTOR WEBER.
PERSONALLY.
SHE'S BEEN WORKING ON THE
BUDGET ITEM I KNOW SHE VOTED ON
ON ON A COUPLE ISSUES ABOUT HOW
MUCH MONEY WE'RE GOING TO GET
THE WAY THE PROCESS WORKS. IS WE
BOUGHT IN THE ASSEMBLY THEN THE
VOTE IN THE SENATE AND IT GOES
TO CONFERENCE AND THE CONFERENCE
A COMMITTEE MEETS NEXT WEEK TO
SEE HOW MUCH FUNDING WE WILL GET
FOR THESE. PROGRAMS I'M HOPING
FOR THE FULL AMOUNT BUT IF IT
ISN'T THE FULL AMOUNT ANY AMOUNT
MORE THAN WHAT WE HAVE NOW WILL
HELP. US GET STARTED ON THIS ON
THIS.
YOU KNOW HOPEFULLY.
LONG TERM FIX FOR WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND.
I LEARNED LAST YEAR I ASKED FOR
A FEW MILLION DOLLARS AND I GOT.
ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
SO MY ASK THIS YEAR WAS TEN
MILLION DOLLARS AND SO ENDED THE
OR MY PERSONAL HOME FROM MY
DISTRICT BY THE IN. TERMS OF THE
BIGGER BUDGET WE ASK FOR SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS WITHOUT WHAT WOULD WE
CALL IT BUDGET DUST.
I WANTED FAVORITE TO LIVE BUT
IT'S BY THAT THAT'S THEM IN THAT
IN THE BUDGET OF A HUNDRED AND
NINETY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS AND
SO THE ASK IS SIXTY. NEXT YEAR
WILL ASK FOUR HUNDRED AND THEN
TWO HUNDRED IN HOPES OF OUT
UPPING THE THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT'S.
ALLOCATED TO.
THIS VERY VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
AND I WANT TO BE AGAIN TRULY
PARTNERS IN THIS AND I SAY THAT
NOT JUST.
BECAUSE IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO
SAY IT'S BECAUSE I HAVE A
PERSONAL ISSUE AND I MY
COLLEAGUES ARE REALLY VESTED AS
YOU CAN TELL I I WANT TO GIVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON OF ROUND
OF APPLAUSE AS WELL.
FOR BEING HERE AND TRULY SHINE
FOR ALL THE OTHER MEMBERS THAT
WERE PRESENT TODAY FOR REALLY.
OUGHT NOT JUST BEING HERE
BECAUSE IT'S THERE. IT'S POPULAR
BUT BECAUSE IT'S THE RIGHT THING
TO DO FAR COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. AND THANK
YOU FOR THE DEDICATION THAT
YOU'VE SHOWN.
AGAIN MY ASK IS THAT WE NEED A
LIST OF ALL THE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE ALREADY ON THE GROUND.
TO IS TO REACH OUT TO US AS TO
WHERE YOU WANT THIS BUT NEXT
CONVERSATION TO HAPPEN WE HAVE.
YOU KNOW SOME FUNDING.
TO HELP US TAKE IT THERE AND.
SO THOSE ARE THE TWO ASKS FOR
TODAY IF YOU HAVE MORE PLEASE
REACH OUT CHRIS TOLD THINK
CRYSTAL CRYSTAL AT WORK REALLY
REALLY HARD THANK YOU CRYSTAL.
I'M SEEING SHE IS INVESTED IN MY
VISION IN OUR VISION AS TO WHERE
THEY SHOULD GO UMBER CRYSTAL HAS
BEEN WORKING VERY VERY HARD ON
MAKING THIS HAPPEN AND SO REACH
OUT TO CRYSTAL AND SHE WILL MAKE
SURE THAT I GET THE INFORMATION.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD YOU KNOW
WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL OF YOU
AGAIN FOR BEING HERE AND I WILL
LIKE TO CLOSE THE COMMITTEE.
HEARING TODAY BUT NOT BEFORE
EVER THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING
OF MANY MORE TO COME SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH